Film Courage: Have you always
wanted to be a cinematographer
or did you want to be a director instead?
Andy Rydzewski, Cinematographer: Cinematography
came to me kind of later and I feel like I
stumbled into it I directing was kind of
always the goal I loved films and I loved
specifically atmosphere I was always
attracted to the atmosphere which
when I was a kid usually meant genre
horror sci-fi fantasy like the fantastical
and I was I think that's what drew me initially
to it is a totally different world and then
over the years especially once I got into
college and grad school more specifically
I was making films with friends I was writing a
lot at the time also my school was small so doing
film mixed with theater so plays and all that and
the more that I did that I loved it but everything
was a little slow like you sit by yourself your
writing your writing your writing directing you
have to organize a lot of things you didn't really
have producers at this school and I started to
pay attention to cinematography knowing my own
thesis film was coming soon and there was nobody
in my school that was very good shooter and so
I just started studying that and other people
started to ask me to shoot their films and
so I started learning cinematography really
by working on other people's films and the
immediate gratification of it became very
addictive like directing it would took me months
to organize a short and whether I was writing the
script or getting it from somebody else it still
took time but cinematography it's just like okay
well let's light the scene now let's shoot it now
and that immediate gratification I think was a big
turnover for me I think I just got addicted
to knowing I can make this happen right now
whereas writing which I still very very rarely
I still do some and I do I still hope to find
my way back to directing I miss directing a lot
I miss interacting with actors not that I don't
in my job now but in a slightly more intimate way
perhaps but yeah it really it was something that
I never aimed for but then it's it just found
its way to me so it's yeah but I but now I love
it I've for a long time have been fond of
saying it's my second favorite job on earth
behind directing but now it's I don't know might
be 1a1b because I really I do love it and I love
the there's almost like your responsibilities
are a bit lessened I hate to put it that way but
there's I watch some directors and they're
being flooded with emails and calls and
texts and all through the night and for me for the
most part assuming my prep went well enough I the
load is a little less and I feel like my quality
of life is pretty good which is sort of a sad way
to say why you've leaned into something but I have
found it to be true so yeah well some people know
some people the idea of one thing sounds great but
then when you actually look at what the duties are
then maybe some people are more visual some people
are more this they're better not even speaking
they just know intuitively what they want yeah
no that's a that's a good point there is a lot of
i've always loved cameras just I've
always been fascinated by cameras and so
as a kid I loved picking cameras up and so there
is something to be said but perhaps I just it took
me a while to just find my way to cinematography
because of that because I just cameras were always
a big part of it and I've always been a visual
learner and all of those things so so maybe it
was inevitable that I would find my way to
cinematography for sure were you good at
magic like I could see you being like a magic
like person that's ventriloquism if that counts
I was I was into ventriloquism for a very small
amount of time but yeah I did originally what
everybody thought I was going to do was draw I
used to draw like crazy really into comic books
and so I just everything I would just draw
draw draw and then that turned into writing
for a long time and but it was really even with
writing my writing was very visually oriented
if that makes sense very descriptive in terms of
again atmosphere I think there's something about
atmosphere that I have a mini obsession with
just creating the the texture of of the of a
world is something that I love deeply and I think
with cinematography I get to do more of that
and what was your thesis film about like it was
a dark it was like a it was very much inspired
by grim fairy tales so my thesis was a young girl
whose mother has passed at the very beginning of
the film we see her only as a as a corpse and her
father turns to drinking and the little girl gets
obsessed with trying to fix her mom and so
it begins if I remember correctly her dad
says something like to the effect of oh her her
heart is is broken it's so she's not around now
and the little girl decides oh if I can
get her a new heart then we'll have a
new she'll be fine and so she goes around and
it takes place in like a sort of fantastical
16th century and she goes around and starts
collecting body parts from various folks so
it's like a little bloody there's a storybook like
a literal storybook I had an artist friend of mine
chris henry draw this whole thing and so it's it
opens with once upon a time opens up and filmed
it in the redwoods in northern california
which was beautiful great production value
and yeah it was a dark dark horror comedy I
suppose yeah I I don't think I would be able to
sit and watch it now without clawing my own eyes
out but it was I was very happy with the attempt
i'm glad I tried something strange I think that's
up my alley strange has always been up my alley
I wouldn't know anything about it what was your
first camera oh first cameras well so when I was
boy i'm gonna say 16-ish I dug up my grandfather's
old super 8 camera and so I started shooting with
super 8 but having no idea what I was doing I
didn't know what any of the settings meant and
I just it's thinking back on it it's sort of
amazing that some of it was exposed I had no idea
what I was just setting it in the middle and so
I did get a few rolls back that were just black
but for the most part everything came out pretty
exposed and so I shot some short films on super
8 for a little while and then and then I think
the the my first camera this would have been
the tail end of college it was a panasonic dvx
100 which was the first it was minidv which is
maybe the worst format in a lot of ways in
terms of actual qual image quality but it
shot 24 frames per second it had really I shot
a lot with it it was a lot of sketch comedy
at the time that I was I've always been very
into comedy and yeah that camera felt like a
a step even though I did I don't know that I ever
got paid for a single job with it I shot a lot
with it which was great and then from there some
years later the panasonic hvx 100 I think the the
hd basically digital version of that I never
owned that but I worked at a company that had one
and they let me use it whenever so yeah I think
those were those were kind of the big camera steps
for me and then with many others in between
a 70 a 5d a7s and eventually an alexa mini
do you still have the mini dv tapes no
unfortunately it's a bummer I about let's
see this would have been 11 years ago my house
that was renting burned down in one of the la
at the time the biggest fire in la and I lost all
of my films I lost all my writing all my art I
used to draw and it was it was it still still kind
of stings but truthfully it was a big reset button
I it's it has helped me with attachment and
having a lack of it it was the year after
my house burned down I just kind of lived on the
road for a year I could fit everything I owned in
a backpack and so I slept on couches I flew out to
hawaii and slept on my buddy's hotel room while we
were working on a movie out there like it was my
life was a bit of an adventure which I think was
good I think it was it was an interesting
life for a time but the at the sacrifice of
losing all basically everything I had created
up until 30 years old essentially was this
the station fire yeah the station fire yeah I
remember it yeah yeah it was it was yeah it was a
strange time strange time it's funny to think
that that's so long ago because it does feel
so relevant to my life like it
really i'm it's altered some of my
way of approaching things and and
purchases feel strange to me still
furniture and I like owning things still feels
a little weird a little ptsd I think but I
my life has been good since then so it's I just
one of the stepping stones I guess who knows
aside from it you losing all
these things and and that being
the horrible like negative side and losing
in a sense your parts of yourself really
went down in that fire do you think it showed you
how temporary things are and you looked at things
in a new light in a positive way that way yeah
I would for sure say the silver lining of losing
everything is that you the idea of impermanence
becomes a lot easier to grasp and I for sure it's
the impermanence of everything life health
friendships you just never I think I take some of
those things less for granted now perhaps I hope
I don't know and I do wonder 20 years from now
what will the scars of that look
like will they still be there will I
I don't know I moved into a house a year
ago after living in someone else's house for
basically 10 years I had like a wing of a house
to myself and when I moved into my place last year
I owned nothing I had no bed I didn't have a
chair a desk I had nothing and so 11 years well 10
years I guess at the time after the fire was the
first time that I was like okay I gotta purchase
some things and it felt it still feels odd I
can feel the weight of those things I liked
I liked the idea that it any particular morning
not to say I would do this necessarily but that
I could just kind of pack up everything into my
car and be on my way and that's everything that's
all I need so yeah I don't know so it's strange
I think i'm still processing all of it in terms
of its ultimate lessons no things do own you it's
true yeah yeah they have a weight for sure yeah
when did you realize you were obsessed with
cinematography okay so I was obsessed with
movies very young and i'm trying to think of when
I became conscious of cinematography even as a job
or a as a position on to be honest I don't know
I think I even probably ahead of cinematography
is I think I was stricken by production design not
realizing that it was production design because
again I was so I've always been so attracted
to the atmosphere being built and so often the
production design is doing especially if
you're leaning into something fantastical
like the movie legend was something I loved as a
kid and the sets are amazing and I think that was
the first time I realized oh somebody's doing this
somebody's making this happen but cinematography
I would think somewhere in college and I think
it's specifically that it was the camera side of
things since I had always enjoyed photography and
just cameras in general I realized somebody on set
is touching a camera and so I think that was the
first inkling but to be honest I don't it feels so
gradual my cinematography and I discovering each
other it almost feels like it's one like a like a
romance where you're like oh we were 12 years old
and we used to play at the beach together and then
over the years you start to be like hey she's
kind of hot or whatever and those little
flirtations like it just didn't occur
to me and then all of a sudden one
day you're like oh I think i'm in
love like this is it's a thing so
I think for me in college when people
started asking me to shoot their films
I think was so being a cinematographer I think
was the first time I started to realize like oh
I really love this because even with films that I
loved I was while I was aware of cinematographers
it I never thought of it as a job for myself
somehow so I don't know it's sort of strange to
think now because that's what my life is kind
of built around is cinematography in a lot of
ways all the things I read about and find myself
fascinated by and I i'm always paying attention
to cameras and lights and and light in general
i'm so conscious of all these things now but
yeah I really don't even remember where
cinematography and I found each other
strange do you think because you went to humboldt
state you got like a double graduate degree yeah
yeah yeah yeah I got two masters up there and and
again it was so one was in screenwriting and one
was in film production and because our school
was so small it was really geared more toward a
documentary and experimental film and I it really
feels like a stroke of luck in timing when I was
there there were other students who joined at the
same time a bunch of talented writers directors
and all of us were geared toward narrative
and because the department was so small
we almost created a path together whereas
normally it was documentary or experimental
we kind of forged our own path of
narrative with the professors as well
and the experimental element really found it's
I really loved experimental film and discovering
like maya darren and stan brackets these like gods
of experimental film but most people haven't heard
of them and I just loved it there were these
weird esoteric bizarre films and I I made films
where I was scratching the emulsion and coloring
that and conforming by hand and having physical
negatives in my hand it I really dug that and I
think it's had a real effect on my approach to
cinematography for sure there's something very
tactile that I lean into I like I like the things
that I shoot to have a a tactile almost messiness
to them it's interesting and I assume that's where
that came from but I don't really know do you ever
question had you gone to another college maybe
they would they would have been more regimented
like did you have a lot of freedom there
yeah we had a ton of freedom in our program and
I the first year that I went there it was a fluke
I went before I went to grad school when I was
in undergrad I did undergrad in massachusetts
umass amherst and they had a domestic exchange
program which I had no I'd never even heard of
and the day I walked into their office I just
asked like hey how does this work and they gave
me a bunch of brochures and they were like oh
here's a book of all the schools that we have
a partnership with you could go to any of these
schools in theory and so I went to the library
I took it right then went to the library sat with
it for a couple hours and I was looking for a
place that had film classes that was not in a city
and that was near the ocean and that was it and it
was like three or four schools that fit that and
humboldt which I had never heard of at the time
the deadline for that was like that day or that
week and so I went back I had my little list
and I went back to the the woman who gave me the
brochures and I asked like how strict are these
deadlines like if I wanted to apply to humboldt
could I still do it she's like i'm not sure let
me check and she goes into her office and she gets
on the phone and she's on the phone for a while
and she finally comes out and it's
like okay you're enrolled for the fall
and I was just like well I didn't even know if I
wanted to do any of this but I just was like screw
it and I just went I went across the country I
went to that school and that year changed my life
dramatically it was really I had been at umass
they didn't have a film program so I was taking
film theory classes they had a sprinkling of those
but no production and I went out to that school
and I wrote plays that got produced I was acting
in plays I was making films hand over fists like
we were all it was just this like I mentioned
there was there were these other students that
were hungry in the same way I was and I just
spent a year producing content constantly
and because the department was small
we just kind of forged our own path
and I think to to your initial question if
I had gone to a school with more structure
I don't know how that would have gone I don't know
structure and I have not always been the best of
friends so I do wonder what would have happened
and I I used to be a painfully shy person and
that year in humble really opened me up and I
do wonder if I went to a school with more rules
maybe I never would have opened up I don't know
and I had writing teachers and film teachers that
I bonded with and the classes were smaller
so you have the opportunity to bond and
yeah I it all it was I remember that was the first
time in my life where I started to believe in fate
I was just like I stumbled into
the school and it changed my life
I think inarguably for the better personality
wise work ethic wise opening my eyes up to
different approaches to art and experimental
film and all these things that I just
I hadn't planned on any of them and then all
of them really just sunk their hooks into me so
I've heard it's a magical place up there not
just the way it looks but also the mindset
yes for sure yeah and i'm i'm more of
I've been in la now for 15 years but I
i'm a nature boy i'm a country boy so up there I
worked really hard but then my breaks I'd go off
into the most beautiful forests in the world to
take a walk and all that and I think that really
nurtured me and and helped my soul a bit for sure
what's the hardest part of being a cinematographer
the hardest part of being a
cinematographer is probably
well I reserve the right to take this back and
but I think well in general I think time is always
the enemy so it's trying to manage time I think
that's a big part of filmmaking and probably life
too is just just time you can never make more
time you can make everything else but you can't
make more time and as a cinematographer
you're always going to be torn between
ooh I could add another light or we could bring
in some negative you can always tweak an image but
the more time you give something now the less time
you'll have in the evening for the scene that's
later so you're constantly compromising so I it's
so it's either the battle with time or the battle
with ego I really i'm the more I work the more I
realize ego really takes up a lot of space on set
and it's not and I don't mean just other people's
ego though I do also mean that but really your own
especially as cinematographer hierarchy gets very
tricky on ice I've always been a feature film nerd
and it's almost easy on a feature the
director's the boss generally like that's
so it's almost a cleaner thing but the more
tv I've been doing it's my job to make sure
that there are visual through lines and
sometimes you have a director who comes in
and maybe wants to do something that isn't in
the language of the show and you try to balance
like okay I want to give the director what they
want but I have to also make sure that the show
runner that we're or whoever the producer whoever
might be the creative through line that they're
getting what they need and that i'm also making
sure that we're not getting off track too far and
finding the places to to curb my own ego
when there are other people telling me
that we need to do something that feels wrong
or or maybe just I don't like whatever that is
and and trying to quiet my ego so that I can
be logical about something like okay is this
just because I want my idea to be right or is
this actually affecting the what we're working
on right now like how much is ego versus something
that's actually for the show and I've been lucky
that over the last four years I've been working
on a lot of series and just really going going
going and it's helped me I think I think if I had
done some of the jobs I've had in the last year
if I had done them five years ago I think I would
have done a significantly poorer job because just
because of my own ego which I hate to say but I
it's something that I've noticed more and more is
keeping my own mind quiet while on set and
learning to listen as opposed to talk and get all
my ideas out it's really trying to yeah navigation
of ego I guess so time or ego it's one of those
two as the probably the trickiest part of my job
I think and this is going to go back to humboldt
state again but do you think in some ways it was
so supportive that when you came to another place
that was maybe more competitive that it was more
difficult to navigate or that's just that's my ego
yeah right no I think it's interesting because
going back to humble and my grad school this
is this is the one of my arguments for film school
actually is to to be in a place where you can fail
constantly like like it's okay it's not only okay
you should fail you should swing for the fences
and fall on your butt like it's I think that's
important and it also because my program was
small and you were doing everything it
did give me confidence for sure so I had
it's easy to be a big fish in a small pond but
when you move to Los Angeles like nobody cares and
I I was I was shooting I was like one of the
only people that anyone would call to shoot
a short up and humble and then I came to
l.a and it took me years before I could
get anybody to let me shoot anything for free
I was gripping and then gaffing for a while and
it definitely yeah I guess that was also tricky
for my ego but again same thing I worked with with
the with a gentleman hollywood heard who's his
name I don't even remember what his real first
name was but he we all called him hollywood and
he was a an older gaffer and he taught me a lot
he and a big part of it was keep it taught me to
keep my mouth shut because I I was used to being
somebody who had opinions that people would listen
to on tiny tiny little sets and he gave me my
first work in Los Angeles on low budget features
that kind of thing and realizing like i'm a small
cog in a very large machine and watching people
make mistakes that I some of them I could foresee
was very frustrating he'd be like oh the sun is by
the time this track is laid down the sun will be
behind those trees like I can see it and they're
like no this isn't your job you could you don't
tell them how to and then I'd watch that happen
so so it was hard to learn to shut up but also
really good for me that's I like to when i'm on
set I encourage my crew to give me ideas I love
gathering ideas it doesn't mean I'll take them
but i'm very open I love collaboration but I also
I do my work and so if something doesn't fit
aesthetically or tonally it's easy for me to just
be like I don't think we're going to do this in on
steadicam I think that that doesn't quite whatever
so I think just yeah I don't know I
guess it's a dance because in in humboldt
my ego probably got inflated and then it got beat
down coming to Los Angeles and and now I don't I
guess I don't know where I sit with with my own
ego always working on it meditating every day and
which is a habit I picked up because of film I
was on a series in albania that was so stressful
I almost had a nervous breakdown like I had a
really tough time and the director meditated
every day at lunch and out of pure desperation
just to try and do anything I started meditating
and now I never I haven't missed a day of
a meditation before a day of shooting in
probably four years I've been yeah so that's
that's helped yeah and for how long a period
of time do you meditate so I meditate it's pretty
quick I do ten my rhythm now is when i'm working
I wake up I do my morning stuff at home and I get
to set early and I meditate for 10 or 15 minutes
in my car and then I get out I have a little
breakfast and and then start the day so it's
10 10 15 minutes every morning before I walk
onto set but always parked right near it and
what happens if you're you're trying to meditate
but then there's this little oh did I bring that
oh didn't I did I remember oh sh what if there's
like this nagging voice about what you're supposed
to do yeah I have I've been meditating for four
years and I've probably I could probably count on
one hand the number of times where a little voice
wasn't talking to me so it's just part of it it's
part of the process and that's fine and I can
always deal with it after my 10-15 minutes is up
so whatever it is it it definitely comes in and
out but I'll just deal with it afterwards usually
usually the 10-minute span doesn't affect anything
so yeah I just let those thoughts go as best I can
what would your advice be for let's say a young
person who comes to a competitive set it doesn't
have to just be la and what I've seen with
competitive environments is there's a lot of
unwritten rules and you'll never you learn trial
by fight you're gonna find out that oh that wasn't
okay but you didn't know it so what would your
advice be and they're they're just someone that
has good intentions they're not trying to climb
up they just think that that's the way to do it
but they're not sure this is like an un sort of
uncharted territory yeah being on set is tricky
for sure for everyone and if you're newer
I think really I think the biggest piece of
advice for anybody who wants to work really in any
capacity on a film set is be kind and be humble
like it doesn't like if you're if you're
right and you're witnessing people be wrong
fine like that you don't need to express that
like it's okay to just swallow some of your
comments and just be really film work especially
narrative like features tv longer shorts they're
exhausting they're so time commerci everything
and once you get to our 14 on day 26 everybody's
exhausted everybody's stressed people miss their
families it's a very film work is very difficult
and the people who you surround yourself by or
who you are surrounded by affect everything your
mood your ability to think and if somebody is
challenging you constantly even if they're right
it it beats you down and you only have so much
energy I think of it sometimes like a battery
just being drained and if you have to spend
five percent of your battery dealing with a
personality like then that's removing five percent
from something else and the people who seem to get
hired more are people who are pleasant to work
with and I think that's something that surprised
me a lot about Los Angeles but it also it just
delights me I never thought that being kind
would help your career but it makes perfect sense
now that i'm on set and I realize how exhausting
people are ever everybody myself included we're
all exhausting everybody needs something from
whether we need affirmations or whatever it is
we're draining we're exhausting as a species so
when somebody is easy and still does their job
it's a magical combination and so I really I think
everybody's eager especially when you're young
and you're new you're eager to get ahead or I want
like this or or just chasing money or whatever it
is I think slowing down and just being in the room
and yeah learning to read a room that's the
other thing so I think being kind and learning
to read a room when it's tense maybe be a little
more quiet when everybody's in a good mood like
that's great jive along with it but being
reading the room knowing when to be quiet
which is just most of the time I think that stuff
all helps but really being kind being humble
I think goes it takes you far in life
I think I'll check back in 20 years
that's great wow I like that story so the guy
he he was you said a gaffer or he was like a
and he's he was kind of saw you and said
like don't don't do this and don't do that
yeah he really he he would get in my ear
and he's sort of he's a big personality so
I don't know I don't know I'd be
I'd be curious I haven't seen him in
15 years probably so I'd be curious
to see how he's doing now but for me
I got frustrated seeing people with way more
experience than me so I thought I knew better
and he was just like hey that's not your job like
that's a big part of it is I had come partially
coming from such a small school and small town
you show up on set you're gonna do a little of
everything sound lighting crafty like you you're
gonna get your fingers in every aspect of it and
being on sets they were still small movies but
you have your lane and I would offer to help other
departments and if they wanted help great and if
they didn't that's also great like it so I think
learning your position and knowing you can't
do everything unless you are so there are some
directors who are great at everything there
are very few of them but there are some who
are just very knowledgeable but that also tends to
lead to micromanagement and people don't tend to
enjoy that people want to feel like collaborators
they want to feel like they have some input on on
have their fingerprints on a project in one way
or another so yeah I think I think just learning
to not just do your job and with a smile on your
face if you can manage it so yeah i'm not sure
if you're okay talking about this but did you
go through a period of time where you were not
able to pay your bills being a cinematographer oh
yeah no i'm happy to discuss that yeah yeah for
sure okay yeah I so I've been in Los Angeles
for 15 years 15 something like that and I've
was I've been broke for probably 11 of them 10
something like that like problematically broke for
five six years and I feel very lucky this is
this is one of the things that I i'm always
very thankful for is I always knew I wanted to
be involved in filmmaking or at least from a very
young age I didn't know if it was realistic my
mother wanted me to be a doctor my whole family's
doctors except for me but I just I was so I just
loved it so much filmmaking the idea of it and
any little taste I got that I was can I slept in
my car my last semester of undergrad I slept in
my car I went to the gym in the morning
to shower like it was it never felt and
it kind of felt romantic I never felt like I was
sacrificing even though I guess I was it didn't
feel that way because I was pursuing this kind
of weird dream and it always and money I will say
it's tricky if you if you're raising a family
and all that but I for me it has always served
me well to ignore money in the jobs I pursue and
all that I have friends who are who are doing
well in let's say the commercial world or the
corporate world in terms of filmmaking and they
they will tell me that they're envious of
me because I I've shot some features and tv
shows but then something will come their way
some low budget feature and they'll say no
because the pay is no good but then they get
frustrated that they're not getting a feature
but they just want it and narrative pays worse
than commercials that's generally the rule and
that's for me ignoring the money and
just chasing the project or the director
has served me very well some of the best
some of the jobs I think about the last show
I shot was penn 15 a hulu series and that
director we've worked together on multiple
projects we shot a series before for cso which
is a defunct streaming service and we did we shot
a web series for I think it was like three days
four days of shooting I think I got paid 100 bucks
and I worked my butt off and still to this
day it's one of my favorite things that I shot
I believe for him he got his his manager from that
he he had a screening it went very well he it kind
of kicked things off for him and at the time when
he asked me to do it I did hesitate I was like oh
that barely pays like it's barely paying me
anything and then I did it and I loved it
I loved the project I love everybody involved a
lot of those people are doing well these days and
it's a piece of my community in Los Angeles
came from that tiny web series so for me
and we'll see now we're we're in a pandemic
as we speak and I haven't worked in months
and I have I was okay with it for a time and
now the anxiety's starting to creep in but I've
been freelance for 15 years and i'm used to all
manner of ups and downs and I keep my overhead low
so that I don't have to chase money I guess yeah
were you actively looking for jobs or because
so much of the film industry just
completely shut down so yeah now i'm I
at this point I have the only thing that
I've done to be proactive really is I have
I can't i'm not very active with social media
and I realize that for my job I probably should
I should make that a higher priority and
I do have friends who are really good with
instagram specifically and I realize that it's
at least potent has the potential to be a good
tool for finding work and so I am now trying to
treat it a little more seriously and trying to
create posts that I would like to see like maybe
a little educational or a behind the scenes or how
did you light this or why is the the color palette
this that kind of thing so i'm trying to now
just so I feel proactive because I don't really
know what else I can be doing right now to find
work I've built a decent network over the
years I have a reputation that I am proud of
but when people aren't calling i'm
genuinely not sure of what one does
and i'm learning i'm trying to figure it out
i'm talking to different people and seeing what
what they think and just kind of trusting that
something will come and the the last show I
shot did well in terms of it's its reviews and
and fine finding an audience so i'm hoping that
that might might put my name on some lists but the
truth is so much of this is a crapshoot I really
don't know how to find work even when a decade
ago I woke up every day and I would start on
craigslist and mandy was a thing and but I was
trying to do that the other day I was like i'm
curious are people posting jobs no during all this
but I've never been sure how to find work I've nev
it's never made sense to me but I have been okay
at building relationships and not in an aggressive
networking way I don't think it's mostly i'm a big
film nerd and I end up bonding with people who are
also film nerds and the directors who I've bonded
with it tends to be somebody who I met somewhere
and we just got to talking about some movie that
we saw and then it snowballs you're like oh have
you ever seen this movie and this and just the
excitement of it and and I think that's one of the
arguments for being in Los Angeles is you are
around other people who are chasing the same dream
and a lot of them you'll find people who are nerdy
in the same way you're nerdy and then you bond
and then going back to what I was saying earlier
about how you are on set that often starts
way before it it could be in a job interview
but ideally it's a social setting you're
meeting a friend of a friend of a friend sat
somebody's birthday and you're like oh I really
liked that person I was like what do they do oh
cinematographer well we have this thing coming
up and I think that's how a lot of Los Angeles
connections get made and I think that was the
downside of going to such a small school is it
really didn't I came to la with zero connections
and I think people who go to usc for instance
which is way more expensive so it has that
downside but I think you are meeting people who
are going to be in the industry for the next
decade at least and I think that gives you a real
head start in a lot of ways and now I don't know
in terms of film education and the debt
or all that I don't know pros and cons but
I think yeah meeting p which again in a
pandemic is tricky I have no idea how i'm gonna
meet people but there are film groups that
are meeting on zoom and I should maybe try
to be more proactive about that but yeah and doing
something like this who knows who knows who will
who will see the interview and be like hey that
guy yeah yeah exactly I want to meditate in my
car with you yeah exactly right so yeah you
never know but yeah yeah I I've never been
good at figuring out how to get work how to summon
work it's definitely one of the we i'm i'm fond of
saying this but I think it's true i'm i'm bad at
the business side of the business so I see a lot
of true artists are that way yeah I've definitely
I know a lot I have a lot of musician friends
and some of the best ones are terrible at every
other part of life yeah so yeah I don't know
what one does with that but yeah you just kind of
trust and and I think I think really the fact that
I've been freelance for so long and I've gone
through such lean times it prepares you for future
lean times so yeah so so far I feel okay I think
I think I told myself i'm allowed to get anxious
next march one year at the one year anniversary
if I still have no work then i'm allowed to start
getting a little anxious 2021 2021 yeah so so i'm
a little ahead of schedule I got anxious for the
first time a week or two ago so I've gotta that's
not part of the deal so I've gotta I've gotta
keep my because I know as soon as I
end up on a set and i'm on week four
and i'm exhausted I'll be like ah remember when
it was a pandemic and I could just sleep whenever
I wanted so I'll be wishing for this downtime
yeah right well if we look if we go back to 1918
for was it the the Spanish family yeah so what
was that two years if we look at the chart
i'm not exactly sure but yeah and if you think
about medical advances are far greater now but
then there's the whole thing does anybody want
to take a vaccine right we don't we won't go
down that slipper state but so I know that's
the thing when you're talking about 2009 and and
station fire and all that that was there was
a recession and that was tragic and we thought
we'd probably never see anything like that in our
lifetime again and now you add a bad economy to
a communicable disease sorry I can't even say the
word but that is is so it's there's new variables
that you've never really been in this yeah yeah no
and I will say I think that's always on the table
I think life is change and if as soon as you think
you have stability and a predictability to your
life I think something's gonna shake it up that's
something and that could be the fire speaking
but that's that's how certainly I try not to take
anything for granted or assume I think also the
film industry in and of itself like the number of
projects that I was getting ready to shoot that
then just fell through it's innumerable the I was
supposed to be shooting a feature this summer that
I was really excited about I had three features
lined up this year and poof but I I've just
in normal times that still happens so I think
being prepared for instability in this industry is
really important and and weighing if that's worth
it I i'm lucky I don't have a wife and kids and so
my anxiety any anxiety that arises is just for
me I would imagine for somebody with a family
you have to provide for like that's that's I
don't see how that couldn't raise your stress
so it's a our industry is pretty cruel
it's it chews you up it spits you out
there's always somebody behind you in
line so I I don't know I think that's why
you you really gotta love it because otherwise
I do not recommend getting into this industry
it's and but i'm lucky because I
do love it I love it I love it very
purely so now we'll see how long that lasts
i'm sure one morning I'll wake up and be like
i'm going to go see if there's work at the gas
station like who knows or you could you said
you love like ventriloquism and things like that
you never know you might make a line of of these
puppets or what there's new things that could
happen that sometimes we don't even know what our
interests are it's true yeah you never know and
again and I try to be open to all those things to
life is change and it's all an adventure and tick
tock who knows how much time you got left so I
think being open to any any other experiences any
other paths that reveal themselves in life like
I don't know take it why not what the heck so yeah
i'm always open to to anything that might come
down the pike if I respond to it that's that's
all I need and then I'll follow that when you look
back at those times when you were trying to find
work and and they were lean times did you lose
faith in yourself did you ever say what I should
have I should have done pre-med hmm yeah I think
in my leaner times there were certainly doubts
that came up like is this plausible the truth
is I still wonder is can I do this for another
10 20 30 40 years and I genuinely don't know so
I think there have there have been doubts
in terms of is this is this a a lifestyle
that I want to continue pursuing I've I that
is probably the bigger one I had a year 2017
which was my first really busy year and I shot
I can't remember it was like 30 40 episodes of
half hour various shows half hour tv it was just
I went from one show to the next to the next
I spent six or seven months in other states
shooting and it was good obviously to be shooting
I was so exhausted by the end of the year that
I felt really burnt out and I got freaked out
that I was like oh no like can I not do this
anymore and I and I it took me two months to
recover just sleeping basically for two months
I seen friends for the first time in a year
and it it was the first time where I got scared
of what can happen in this industry on the flip
side I was used to being broke and not having
work and that brought its own anxiety and then
doing 13 hour days for a full year just
ground me down mentally and physically
and then and so now I when I have the luxury
of of choosing jobs I now pay more attention
who am I working with is this really something
that I feel a pull toward and trying to weigh
pros and cons of everything because it's
yeah I really don't know I really have
I am scared of this industry I've watched it
take more talented people and spit them out
and turn them bitter and that's something i'm
really worried about I don't I don't want that
to be the case with me I want to make sure that I
still love what i'm doing for as long as possible
and part of that is meditation making sure
I know that so going for evening walks
for me is like a huge thing it calms me down
and all that so when i'm working on set on
on a show I have a lot of strict rules I have
dietary rules and sleep rules that I follow
really closely because of that one year I just
it was so intense that it freaked me out and now
and built so you're taking that experience
and combining it with years of being broke
and having doubts but always still just kind
of okay just keep working on your craft and
hope I guess hope that something works out
but yeah I don't know it's really it's a
it's all scary when I really think about this
industry it's a tough it's a tough one to feel
good about unfortunately and i'm hoping who
knows this pandemic maybe i'm hoping it'll turn
into I've heard some shows are switching to french
hours which means instead of a 12 and a half hour
day with a half hour lunch in the middle is you
you work for 10 hours straight you don't stop for
lunch it's a walking lunch and I would love that
to go home two hours earlier is definitely worth
not sitting down for a half hour for lunch but it
helps your immune system we're learning more about
what lack of sleep does to your body and it's not
good so I do hope that be it a certain director
or a certain studio or whatever it is that
quality of life maybe could move up the list
in terms of priorities I think that'd be lovely
I don't have a lot of faith in that happening but
I do hope that there's a way to be
doing this into my well into my 70s and
feel like i'm still taking care of my life I
don't know if that's possible but one can dream
we interviewed a gentleman who said that a lot
of hollywood work is like temp work you're kind
of swinging from one job to another and it's never
where you're really landing in one spot yeah but
on the flip side you could say well there's
a lot of people that had corporate jobs that
they were just given a severance package
and pushed out the door yeah so nothing is
really guaranteed absolutely yeah no
it's it's true I think the nature of
most film work or at least the film work that I
do is there just isn't stability the they're just
and there won't be I remember years ago this
would have been this was probably 20 years ago
I saw an interview with kevin bacon and he was
is still I believe married to kira sedgwick and
it was them and kevin bacon has been around since
I was a kid and he said that after every project
when it goes quiet he gets very nervous he's
like oh no am I ever going to work again.
and I remember that sticking out to me like wait
kevin bacon is worried about getting work and
now that I've been in the industry for a little
while i'm like oh right like there's just no you
have no idea if you will be even if you're
on top of the world two years from now maybe
nobody remembers your name or you shoot a
project that bombs or whatever it is it's
such a competitive world and I think I don't think
it's a good industry to base your life on if you
want to build a healthy family and I hate saying
that because it is an industry I love so dearly
but having a relationship when you're gone 80
hours a week and you come home you're exhausted
I don't know you you have to have a special
partnership to make that work I think it's
very stressful on all your relationships
romantic friend all that and I I don't know I
think mostly I like to put that out there
it doesn't nothing is good or bad it just
is like and that's just a fact of our
industry and I think it's important for
people to realize that because it's I think
there are a lot of romantic ideas going in
but the reality of it is and especially now
I don't know will movie theaters open back up
period i'm sure they're going to open up in some
capacity but our world is changing and streaming
is now huge there are more tv shows being
made than ever in the history of of hollywood
but there are no more residuals almost entirely
gone and that's how a lot of writers and directors
and actors maintained a career is that you were
getting residuals from old projects but they don't
have residuals on any of the streaming services
so the future of our industry is very uncertain
but the flip side is is if you if you just look at
the the art of making and between youtube and all
these shows on netflix and hulu and amazon and
all these there's more work and creation being
done than ever before it's just the money is the
trick but money is always the trick I suppose sure
but when you look at your imdb and just your
your body of work it would be i'm surprised
to hear you question that but I think that's a
healthy questioning though just being realistic
yeah yeah I think I think that's part is not
taking it for granted and not never assuming
that the future is going to be what the present
is because it probably won't be and I've shot
I've only ever shot one project that anyone has
heard of and and that so I think I've shot 10
seasons of tv and one got it was a hit to some
capacity at least for its size nobody's ever heard
of the features I shot like it's you never know
what's gonna go in what direction and so for me
it's really important that I love the work the
craft which I do because you have no control over
the other elements of it and so I try to when
I when I can pay attention to who am I working
with the people make a real difference just in
terms of quality of life day to day but yeah
you never know what's gonna work or what's not
gonna work or what anybody will find I've shot
I shot I don't remember now four or five series
for go 90 which was a verizon streaming service
which doesn't exist anymore so even even the full
streaming service the the channel just ceased to
exist let alone those shows but I loved the work
and i'm proud of the work we did on a lot of those
shows I really I hope they find themselves at
home because some of them are really good shows
but again I have no control over that and
so learning to let go helps is you just
control what you can which is on set on the day
you do as good a job as you can be pleasant to
work with enjoy it because that's that's
still your life day to day there so yeah
it's weird it's very it's very strange it's
depressing when I think about the realities of
the industry I tend to get pretty discouraged
I because I would like to I would like to
put some roots down buy a house one day
or whatever that might look like and
I don't know when or if or how that'll go so
yeah but for now I still love the work like I get
excited I just read a script this week for a
feature that may or may not happen and in the
new year and it's like oh yeah how would I shoot
this shot and who how what's the look of this
I still get really excited about that so I let
I let that lead me but i'm in my 40s so you are
okay I did not know that I thought you were much
younger okay yeah no no it's yeah it's the years
yeah it's sleeping well it's a pandemic
okay well I gotta give you that
i'm sure there's other folks out there that are
in a similar boat they're looking for work they're
ready for work but it's not there or whatever the
case may be how do you keep yourself in check you
said you have a meditation practice yeah so I know
myself well enough at this point and i'm still
learning I've figured out all my quirks but I know
that if I don't go for walks I will start to go
crazy going to the movie theater has always been
a big thing for me I always feel very at peace in
a movie theater but that is not an option these
days so trying to I've not gotten myself out to
nature often enough but I know that that usually a
few days of camping will usually kind of reset me
but how I eat and making sure
there's some exercise in my life
and I almost take it like medicine it has
nothing to do with oh today's a good day
to exercise or I feel like exercising no
no no like I have to because I will lose
my mind otherwise and so a part of it is really
just being able to have the discipline I guess
which is for me feels strange to say because I
don't think of myself as a disciplined person but
for anything that anything regarding filmmaking
I've always been able to convince myself
to do something for the greater good so
keeping myself healthy for my own life
maybe doesn't work but to keep myself healthy
so that i'm a better filmmaker so that hour 13
i'm still energetic that's somehow always been
able been a way that I've been able to keep myself
happy and healthy to some degree and I've
always struggled with anxiety and so I have
these little things that I just know I need
to do or I could lose a handle and who knows
just go crazy so here's johnny here's johnny
exactly no I mean I make light of it but I think
a lot of we're all there in somewhere and because
this is uncharted territory and and we thought
we'd seen the worst with the great recession
and then there's so many aspects that we're just
this is been a very trying year in so many
ways for sure yeah yeah and I will say
gratitude is a big that's something i'm really
trying to practice is just being thankful for the
fact that I shot a show that found an audience
and that people like i'm so grateful for that
after years of just grinding and it felt like
I was banging my head against a wall and then
it's like oh people like this that's great
and it feels good but it's also like that's
already gone and so just to be grateful that
something like that grateful for my health
anything that you can be grateful for I think
goes a long way I think it's easy to to spiral
in a global pandemic in a country that is pretty
divided and a lot of anger and frustration I think
I don't it's dangerous you don't want to ignore
anything but is finding the things that make you
bring you some sort of peace and even joy I think
is so important remember why why do you want to
live this life like why oh yeah right like hugging
I remember hugging hugging's pretty good i'm
assuming we'll do that again one day so there's
just yeah trying to be grateful for as much as you
can and when I moved into my new house I bought
myself a really nice tv and I was like oh this
is really expensive I don't know if I should but
I did knowing that I had a show coming and I was
like okay I can rationalize the cost but now in
the pandemic I love that I have this huge tv and
i'm watching all manner of things and it's a nice
little treat and I can't go to a movie theater but
I have a nice setup at home which I didn't have
forever so i'm thankful for that gratitude I think
is a good a good tool hard to exercise but yeah
what's your favorite thing to watch on this new tv
now oh man what I've been really i'm all over the
place but I have I love watching a movie from like
the 70s or 80s where it has this
like beautiful film grain and I love
watching the grain because my the tv is really
nice and the the blacks like go really black so if
you watch somebody like gordon willis a legendary
cinematographer his work he really leaned into
people called him the prince of darkness and
you watch these images that are really dark but
they have this grain dancing through it film
grain is such a I have such a like a romantic
nostalgic reaction to it so it makes me really
happy to watch films with a ton of grain dirt
it's funny I have this clean tv and my favorite
things are the the dirty images you'll love those
yeah that's awesome now I love sometimes watching
90s 80s talk shows I love phil donahue jenny jones
there's just something you can't I don't know
there's something very romantic about I know
it sounds yeah really but there is nostalgic
this like phil donahue and the hairstyles and
totally yeah yeah nostalgia is a superpower yeah
for anyone who wants to learn cinematography what
are some of the best exercises they can do right
now well if you're trying to learn cinematography
right now I would say take out your phone and
just shoot images and try to edit them together I
think that's a bit a big part of shooting at least
for narrative but I would assume this is true of
anything but I i'm more narrative is my field
is the the way a sequence comes together
is a big part of my job it's not just pretty
images pretty images are great they're really fun
but it's how as something as basic as wide shot
and a couple close-ups but getting used to that
watching if you're filming a person this was a big
thing I remember when I started to learn this and
working with when I was inexperienced and working
with inexperienced directors and an actor would
finish their last line and then they'd start
walking his directors would always have me
follow them and then there was no place to cut and
I realized like oh but if you let them exit frame
and then you cut right there it's cleaner
as opposed to a moving shot that then just
cuts and so our phones are wonderful cameras
they're better than the cameras I started with so
like I there's no shame in shooting
with a phone when everybody's got one
so I think doing that but then yeah on your phone
they have editing programs or whatever so whatever
is whatever you have at your fingertips use that
but trying to learn how something comes together I
i'm not super tick tock familiar but I've seen
some videos on there and I have to say it's pretty
incredible watching some of the edits some of them
are unexpected it's quick it's there's a rhythm to
it and I guess maybe that's a part of it too is
the rhythm of how a sequence comes together so
I think shooting but more specifically shooting
and editing so that you see what doesn't work
because it's really making mistakes that's how
you're going to get better is by screwing up
yeah how did you begin editing films
when you first got your camera well
let's see my first when I the first editing
I did was super eight so I guess that was
film and it was you had this little box where you
cut it and so you're you're literally holding up
images and you're taping it together so it's like
proper old school which really makes you think
about what you're shooting now with digital you
can just shoot shoot shoot and I think that can
be it's wonderful but it can be dangerous because
you're not making as many decisions ahead of time
and i'm a believer in at least doing things
thoughtfully and then experiment off of that
but after that I boy I think I've edited every
which way I've edited on a flatbed edited
film by hand I did what I had like a a sketch
comedy show I did at my local cable access and
that was editing vhs to vhs but you had to edit
it linearly so it wasn't non-linear edit so it was
you'd pick your shot from here and then on this
other I barely even remember it I remember it
being a big pain in the butt though and so I
yeah I edited I think yeah every single way
that you can edit I think I've tried and now i'm
getting further and further away from it because
i'm shooting I have a few directors well maybe
not even a few maybe just a couple who involve
me in the edit but usually I shoot and then that's
it I don't see it again until it's time for color
but some directors will send me rough cuts and
ask for some my thoughts and I love that because
I consider that all part of my job the rhythm
of a sequence and how it feels how it progresses
i'm I love talking to editors
rather directors in terms of editing
I think talking to a director about editing
how a sequence will come together tells you
a bit about the tone like starting wide ending
up close something as basic as that but the
movement of a thing is the sequence going to end
static are we gonna do we want the whole thing to
so so for me editing is very
connected to cinematography
which is dangerous because often i'm kept out of
that part of it so yeah how has the rhythm changed
over the years I know you said earlier that you
were able to get a big screen tv and you're you
love watching the film grain of old movies but
how is the rhythm from old movies to now changed
yeah I think a lot about rhythm of modern film
versus versus older films because audiences
are we're we're used to montage we're used to
you you see a 30-second commercial now can have
I don't I don't even know how to hazard a guess it
could have 300 cuts in it like it it but audiences
are savvy so they can take that in the question
is what is helping your message a bit more I have
over the last few years and this is the influence
I think of a specific director I worked with
charles hood he is very aware of when edits come
and he he has really influenced how I think of it
is there there's some kind of a quote it might
be walter merch and i'm sure i'm butchering it
but every cut every time you cut you're letting
the audience off the hook so it's sort of this
idea of as a scene is even if it's just dialogue
just two people talking if you're able to block it
out in such a way or just a walk and talk they're
walking and you're just the camera's leading
if you can let that shot linger it seems
to me that you're more invested in the in
the scene and as soon as it starts cutting and
then it cuts and then it cuts and it cuts that
it's being almost pieced together later and
I do think there's something about that that
I don't know it almost reminds you that you're
watching a film or something whereas when
shots are longer and you hold for longer which
is hard to do because that can get very boring
but if you can block a scene well and
the actors in conjunction with the camera
and they sort of you can land in a close-up
and then this actor moves here and they go
and the camera moves you it's a dance and if
that's choreographed well I think that's about
the best that you can do is fewer cuts and and a
part of it is also watching filmmakers who I love
like paul thomas anderson somebody I love one of
the great filmmakers working he does not cut a ton
he he let he lets the scenes breathe but that's
that's not for everyone it's not to say it's right
or wrong but in terms of keeping people in in
the story that's something that I think helps I
think that's a tool that really helps people stay
engaged is fewer cuts now we'll see how I feel a
few years from now but currently that's something
that i'm trying to get better at is choreography
what makes a beautiful shot what makes a beautiful
shot well beautiful is a tricky word I think um
yeah that's boy I don't even know how I would
begin to answer that because a beautiful shot well
there is a basic thing to to me backlit something
that's backlit if the light is behind coming
through that that's always a good place to start
but beauty is such a strange word because there's
I think at least for my work working in long-form
narrative I think beauty is all relative to the
story so it's really what what keeps you my
translation I suppose of that question would
lean me toward like what fits a scene like what
what if the emotion of the scene is loneliness
the word beauty is going to be interpreted
differently what's a beautiful way to shoot
loneliness or a beautiful way of shooting madness
and then so is beauty actually beauty or is it
I think I think it's all just relevant to the
story and the intention of a moment or a scene
and so there are spots where ugly is beauty which
I which I like I like I like that it's malleable
and it should be because any director
is going to interpret the same script
in their own way any cinematographer
is going to interpret it their own way
so beauty yeah beauty it's interesting
because I have a director who maria marioli
who she has an aesthetic that I really
like and so shooting with her is
pleasurable because it's almost it's just it's
almost the cleanest definition of beauty in
a way like we've we've tended anything that
we've done together we've just tried to make
beautiful in the most simplistic terms like
beautiful people beautiful places beautiful
costumes beautiful light and it's really
fun to do that I really love doing that
but she might be the only director who I
work with where I ca the word beautiful
even fits everywhere else it just feels so
relative to the moment like what's the the
intention almost becomes more important
than beautiful so I feel like that's not
much of an answer but it's so hard the word
beauty for my jaw I actually what I'll add to this
I was on facebook I have a few cinematography
groups that I was part of and I noticed every
time I would get off I would be on there for a
little bit and every time I'd get off I'd feel
really bad about myself and it was because people
were posting beautiful stills from commercials
music videos whatever it was and I'd look at
their stills and I'd just be like I've never shot
a still that looks like that that looks beautiful
like that and it really was getting to me
and then I was working on a show and I was
thinking about it as I was on set and I was
like well this shot could we it's not beautiful
and I was like wait wait no no this isn't supposed
to be beautiful like the the last show I shot
Pen 15 that was one of the mantras is like
no beauty it is not a place for beauty and
that's we had a new gaffer come in for season two
and he'd light a close-up and we'd be working
on it and he'd bring in a little fill light or
whatever an highlight or rim light whatever and
i'm like no no no you we got to get rid of that
that's too beautiful like if shots were beautiful
on that show we would axe them we would we would
try and ugly it up a little bit so yeah so on that
show beauty was the enemy in a way which is tricky
that's interesting I watched both trailers season
one season two and it looks hilarious I'd love
to watch the the full show is that because it's
supposed to show the awkwardness of like junior
high or what i'm not sure exactly how old they
are but yeah yeah they're they're junior high
and yeah it's a show about awkwardness and and
it's supposed to play real it's a weird setup
there are 30 year olds playing 13 year olds with
other actual 13 year olds but we wanted to play it
naturalistic and so you don't want like you don't
want close-ups to look beautiful you don't want
there was nothing about puberty
that felt beautiful to me
and so that was a big part of it and so we we
uglied up the image a lot we added noise we shot
with noise in camera and then we added grain and
we would make sure it wasn't too saturated and
it was it was a real dance but that was the the
mantra is and that came from from the creators
they were like we don't want a beautiful show we
want this to there was a show a movie that we used
as reference welcome to the dollhouse which
is yeah and it's a great like 90s indie movie
and that's what they kept saying is
like how would we shoot this as a 90s
indie movie where we don't have resources what
how would we approach this and making sure to
not make something beautiful because often I
think that's what a lot of cinematographers
think their job is is to make beautiful images
and I don't think that's the job I think I think
you're there to create help create a story and
help hold up a story in that the the atmosphere
that you're creating the visuals you're creating
now that doesn't mean beauty doesn't belong there
but it's in conjunction with the story where are
the relationships where are the characters where's
the arc right now and leaning into beautiful shots
that would be great on a reel I think is a very
dangerous way to work is that because you're
always kind of competing with yourself and you're
taking yourself out of the trueness of the story
in terms of how do you mean well because I was
thinking like cinema verite you're going to just
you're not you just want to show exactly what's
there right but so much of it now is is trying
to top not only your work but other people's
work whether it's on instagram or whatever right
yeah no that's interesting because there is yeah
there is there is something and I do think about
this is how to make something stand out in a in
a world full of images and who are you comparing
yourself against I think I had I had I almost feel
like a an aesthetic breakthrough watching the show
atlanta I because I was working in all these half
hours which I never thought that's where I'd end
up but I've been chewing all these half hour shows
and I was struggling I was like how can
you like I want to make something that's
cinematic that still feels like i'm shooting a
feature and how do you work that in but I think
then seeing a show like atlanta and there was
another show at the time I loved dick it was
on amazon and very different shows but both
of them have a rawness to them and atlanta
the way that they shoot that is amazing they're
they're basically trying to break the sensor of
the alexa they're under exposing by several stops
and then pulling it up so that they're pulling out
the noise which is the opposite of how you're
taught and the opposite of how mo most people
are shooting for clean and I want everything
kind there's a perfect eye light and a rim light
and then atlanta came along and it's so it looks
like somebody buried it underground for a month
and then dug it up and dusted off and like
here's your show and I loved it because it
has a personality it fits with the the show like
the story line the characters they're broke and
they're struggling and I for me it really I felt
like it almost it was like I took training wheels
off of my bike because I was shooting these
shows for people and they're they're for other
people show runner or a production company or
whatever directors and so I was like well I
don't I was like very careful what about noise
people have a weird reaction to noise so you
have to shoot clean make sure there's enough
light and then I was like well wait now I want
if they can do this and this is my favorite
show I've seen in years then what can I do
for my shows that helps them and then I started to
look at a lot older lenses and I started to really
push myself a little bit more in terms of not
attaching to beauty like don't don't let beauty
be the leader I think that became a big part of my
mantra not to say I won't shoot beauty but there
needs to be a reason for it to be beautiful and I
find it interesting that you're not interested in
documentary or it's not that you don't like
it but that you're more drawn to narrative
yeah I love documentaries I but part of what I
am drawn to with filmmaking is the creation of
atmosphere and I think in documentaries you can
absolutely do that but i'm not as good at it so
I have a friend who is a great documentary
filmmaker and I like watching him because it
it opens my eyes up to the possibilities because
now documentaries are becoming so cinematic and
that to me is very exciting that people the way
people shoot interviews now is so much more daring
than how it was just 10 years ago and so for doc
because I do like the dirtiness of life and the
dirtiness of images I do think I've got some good
docs in me to shoot but yeah as of now it just
hasn't hasn't come my way but I would love to okay
what are the basics of getting a great shot with
any camera from an iphone to dslr yeah I suppose
it's a little bit like your previous question
about a beautiful shot like what makes a great
shot because it's so it's so reliant on context so
any type of any shot is where is this going to
fit into the montage of images so so its place
is really more of what I think about but on a
technical level there are certain things that I
will always be careful of seeing usually you
want to see unless there's a reason you don't but
seeing an actor's eyes is important or at
least one eye because we we I think as humans
we connect to eyes even if you take googly
eyes and you put them on a fork suddenly you
can bond with that fork like it suddenly has human
characteristics so I think eyes are a big thing to
I don't think about that consciously but I
know when i'm looking at a shot i'm shooting
figuring out where the eyes are and can you
see them and are there other things in a
frame that are drawing your eye as opposed to an
actor's face that's a big part of it so I think
maybe the way I'd put it is I want to know in
a shot where do I want the audience to look
and how do I want them to
feel when they look there
and so if you have a big wide shot and there's
an actor somewhere but there are other elements
in the frame like a big turquoise teddy
bear or a big shiny something or other
I want to make sure and maybe that helps
the scene and maybe that helps the shot but
I need to know what a shot is intended to do
the ideal is and then I can work from there and
often you end up with a frame you start with
a frame rather where there's too much pulling
the eye and I know this shot you need to go to
that actor right away so that means we need to
knock down this wall this wall is too bright so
let's make sure and knock this light down so it's
not hitting that wall this these sometimes
there's something like an element of costume
that like oh in this shot these red boots
are too much maybe we frame them out maybe we
but it becomes like I guess that's really what it
is for me is it becomes about what's the intention
and where do you want people to look and then you
just start almost chiseling you you're you're like
it's a sculpture and you're trying to get rid of
the pieces that don't need to be there so that
people are drawn to the piece be that through
composition or lighting or color or size and frame
but I think that would be how
I would approach it and then
in terms of different cameras have different
latitudes so like a an alexa has 15-ish stops
of latitude so you can have your dark to your
light but an iphone is significantly less and
if something if there's a white spot that
is blown out is just no information and it
that can it can be ugly and it can pull
your eye because it's so bright and bare
so there are technical limitations to different
sensors and that also can be a part of it is
just something that's that's less artistically
driven and more technical and you're like well
this this camera the sensor is going to break
unless we knock down this light and shoot it all
within a better latitude but again the intention
is the same it's because you don't want them
looking at the wrong thing and and having their
mind drift to something else you you're sort of
trying to be intentional about everything within
a frame what is lighting and why do we light
lighting yeah it's funny when I
started lighting in grad school it was
purely motivated by exposure I was shooting
on film I started shooting on reversal 16
which is difficult to light and does not have
much latitude and if you screw up it's gone
and so I was lighting purely to have exposure
so if you looked at some of the films that
student films that I had lit there was nothing
attractive about them but they were exposed but
now I suppose it goes back to like your
question about a great shot or something it's
intention it's always intention so it's trying
to enhance whatever mood you're looking for
is be that something is beautiful or scary
or and there is also I don't know where this
where or when this started but when i'm on set
very often there will be and I don't know what
it is and this is tricky is I'll be looking at
an image on monitor and we'll be lighting it
and it won't feel like anything that's what I'll
say like this isn't something like this isn't I
don't what does it need and and sometimes
I don't know and so I'll go back to okay
when I when i'm feeling lost like a shot isn't
working I'll go back to what is the scene where
is this character right now and okay if this is
the emotion what does that mean to me in terms
of lighting and then I interpret it however I
interpret or I talk to my gaffer or director or
key grip and and I'll kind of talk it out and feel
it out and sometimes it takes some experimenting
but there is this thing it's not the best way to
work but it's how I've worked for years now where
we'll start futzing if i'm if i'm feeling
like this shot isn't doing what I wanted
to do the light isn't doing what I wanted
to do like well what if we turn that off
and and we'll well what if okay maybe
take away the diffusion there and then
something will happen and i'm like oh this is
something like I don't like now it feels like
something it like has personality to it and
it's such a it's really difficult to explain
because the truth is I often don't know why
I can't I do all my prep work so I try to
marinate in in the show's intention
it shows mood a show's atmosphere
but then when you're shooting shot after
shot and you're on the the 1000th shot of a
show that you're shooting and you're trying to
find something and it's not there I really and
I part of it feels like a little bit of magic I
don't know what that is but the light i'm ver i'm
always very conscious of light and sometimes it
just doesn't feel right and I don't even know what
that means like what is right what if there's no
such thing as right or wrong but something in me
is not responding to what we're doing
and very often it's because of the light
and so it's not much of a specific answer but that
is something and the leader is the intention the
intention of the scene the intention of like just
just trying to think of where your characters are
and sometimes a light can be too dominant or
sometimes it's not enough or sometimes it's
drawing the eye to the wrong place because
it can just like a door frame and a shaft of
light like these are all ways to direct the eye
and so I think for light it's just another tool
another way to direct the eye and direct intention
or mood I guess so a bit of a babbling answer but
it's kind of how I feel about it sometimes
it just is this mishmash of concepts that
you're trying to hone in and then something
clicks you're like yeah that's what it is
it's weird and referring back to Pen 15 your hulu
project the two two one two you said with that one
it was not to make scenes pretty right so with
the lighting again you were not using any kind
of fillers or yeah it was so yeah we approached
so so the show's naturalistic in general and so
some of the basics are if we're in a bedroom
the light is going to if it's bedroom daytime
and that's a big part of it I work with the script
supervisor very closely for a number of reasons
but one of them is I like to track time of day
it doesn't mean i'm going to always stick to it
but I always am checking with her i'm like okay
so this scene is this like two o'clock and she's
like actually no it's like five o'clock and so
some i'm like oh okay so then we'll we'll lower
the sun that's coming in a window so it'll and
we let how it might actually be lead the scene
that that'll at least be if you think of it
as like a hunk of clay that you're shaping
you just getting the hunk is like where to even
start and that's often what it is it's like okay
it's 5 p.m we're about to go to dinner with
these kids so it should not so it should be
a little darker let's start and so part of
it is smoothing out transitions because the
next scene is just night and so it's like okay
well you don't want to jump from noon to night
unless you want to jump from noon to night and so
you let the the way it would actually be you let
that be the leader so a lower sun coming in the
side and then you decide with with everybody the
art crew and the directors like okay these blinds
open closed it's gonna change the look in the room
and you can intention should always be the leader
but sometimes you're just you're like okay I don't
this is too bright okay well then maybe we throw
a tree branch in front of it try and break it up
we diffusion or maybe it's a cloudy day you want
it to feel like a cloudy day or feel like a sunny
day and these are all decisions it's it that's
really what a lot of it is it's just a ton of
small decisions that hopefully are being led by
a concept and then eventually you find yourself
in a place that feels right and I think that helps
I think when you lead with intention and what the
character's state of mind is at a particular
time it really helps because you can make tons
of decisions are the lights on in the room are
they off is the overhead on or is the lamp on
are the blinds open or the blind's closed is it
cloudy is it sunny is it rainy is is the sun over
here because you decide was or should we put the
sun there it you can get overwhelmed by options
but if you have places to start if the story
if the characters that at least gives you can
at least point your ship in a direction and
I think that for me at least is huge that's
everything otherwise I'd go insane because you
can light any scene a million different ways
there were a lot of scenes where the the two
protagonists were in front of their lockers
and sort of like the horrific halls of the junior
high and and sort of the the the bareness and
ugliness of of you're on display for everyone yeah
yeah no and that's and we debated especially in
season one when we were shooting locker scenes by
the locker in the ugly hallway you're like well
the light people tend to look better if the light
is coming from the non-camera side just in terms
of if you're just no intention or anything it's
just nice if it's coming from the opposite side
people it'll be flatter if it's coming from the
camera and so we'd start to lean into that but
then we're like well but they're in the school
hallway where they feel exposed and they feel
like uncomfortable so maybe that's actually good
is that you do it what might be the wrong way
and and and you're juggling those decisions
and sometimes your intention is one thing and
then you look at it and you're like well it just
doesn't work and then you try it another way and
for whatever reason it works and you respond to
it but I think that's also part of it is being
in being in tune with everything and seeing
what you respond to because it's just so
arbitrary in a way the way that i'm going to
respond to something doesn't mean everyone will
but you hope that if if your intentions are dialed
in and that's what's leading your decisions that's
kind of the sum of all of those parts leads to it
feeling the way you want it to feel I guess what
is color temperature and why is it important yeah
color temperature is a is an interesting one I so
in terms of just its beginnings traditionally now
it's changing because of leds but traditionally
homes are lit with tungsten which is a around
3200 it's a warmer color temperature and daylight
is 5600 6000 sunlight color temperature which is
bluer and so that's kind of the general starting
point I would say for color temperature 3200 is
tungsten which traditionally is home interior
and 56 is 5600 is sunlight and outdoors
which is bluer and then from there
there's everything and so I was fond for a
while of shooting scenes that that were like
if we were inside in the daytime and
there were a couple lamps on I would shoot
I shot I think two whole series the whole
thing basically the whole thing at 4 400
camera setting and so that meant every lamp was
a little warm and all daylight was a little cool
and I really there's something about that that
I really like but now the last couple years for
whatever reason the projects i'm on or if it's
my own personal aesthetic I don't really know
I've gotten more conscious of trying to match
and choose any pops of color very carefully
so if you're shooting inside and it's well
evening so evening can be a tricky time
to try and light because it's like oh in your life
there's a point where you're in your house where
you turn on the lights like where it's getting a
little too dark but there's still light coming in
and so figuring out if you're in a scene again
intention is the leaders do you want it to feel
very cozy in the house and maybe you're gonna
shoot right if you shoot right at 3200
then everything in the house will feel
quote unquote normal but then that little blue
light coming in will feel a little extra blue
or you can say oh this is that transition and it
was just afternoon and now we're starting to feel
like the evening is coming on and there's still
that twinge of daylight outside so we're gonna
stay at 5000 in camera let's say and then you turn
on the lights in the house and it's very warm and
then that feels new or different so there are ways
to play it that give just this edge of some kind
of emotion one way or another like and so that
I think that's the easiest way to talk about
how to start with it but you can also make all
of your lights all one color temperature and
then everything is just even but color contrast
is something that more and more i'm becoming
very conscious of is if you want something to
feel very blue then sometimes it helps to have
something orange because you need that contrast
which is very interesting because if you start
watching scenes that are just blue blue blue
every over and over and over your eyes our eyes
are pretty incredible and they will adjust very
quickly and so that blue the same exact blue if
you watch it for five minutes by the time you're
at that fifth minute is gonna feel white because
we adjust very quickly but if you hold color
contrast somewhere a little orange or whatever
that is you keep the eyes anchored in a way and
so that because that's something that I really
I've always been conscious of but I worked with a
colorist who season one of penn 15. he brought an
element of color contrast that I think really
helps that first season season two is kind of
a different look but season one he was he started
adding a little bit of blue to our shadows and to
kind of contrast with skin tones and some of the
production design and I loved it but it's nothing
I intended going in and that ended up coming in
during our first week of shooting he was there
helping us create luts so color temperature is one
of the big tools for sure color of any kind and
color temperature is where it begins because every
and especially now using leds you can dial in
literally millions of colors and so what do you
do with that that's a lot of power and a lot more
decision making so it's yeah it's a it's a it's a
dance and it's a tricky dance for sure you can go
too far or you can go not far enough so yeah
well if you go too far does that make it look too
artsy and then it takes you out of especially when
you talked about in the height the halls of the
junior high it's he wanted to be more stark
and like oh wow everybody's on display here
right good and bad yeah well so again it goes
back to what's the intention of the project
because there are there are shows I would love to
shoot a show with a ton of color I did a show that
was kind of a mockumentary years ago it was about
these djs and so because it was djs these really
rich guys with not great taste and they're live
in this big dj world we were using color all over
the place and it was a blast it was really fun
but that we did that because it enhanced the
the the feeling in the world whereas Pen 15
there wasn't the color really is in the costumes
the costumes are very colorful in Pen 15 and the
bedrooms of the of the girls are a ton of color in
there and so for me it became about letting the
lights be a little more natural and just using
colors to dictate time of day mood or enhance
or bring back skin tones that kind of thing
but yeah the color of those shows because they
are colorful shows but my end is not colorful
at all we were draining color out very often
so it's a because that's another part of it is
production design costumes the actors themselves
like what are their skin tones these are all
pieces of the puzzle and you're trying to make
it all kind of fit and not be make it consistent
and no no one element overwhelming another
like it's like a soup if you put too much
ginger in a soup then suddenly it
overwhelms everything else so yeah
zoom versus primes which are better yeah there's
so zoom lenses and prime lenses they both have
pros and cons for sure and it's a big it's a big
subject traditionally zoom lenses are slower so
meaning you can't let as much light
in or they need you to have more light
whereas prime lenses this is not a rule
it's just traditionally it's how it lays out
so prime lenses tend to be faster
so in terms of a t-stop or an f-stop
you can open up more and let it have a
shallower depth of field let more light in
but you a prime lens is like a 25 millimeter
and that's all it is 25 is a 25 whereas a zoom
let's say because there's also a huge
range of zooms you can have a 25 to 78
or you can have a 25 to 250 and when these
lens and some of these zooms are huge
so there's a l there's a lot of decision making
that goes into what lenses you're using and
the prime versus zoom is one of the big ones
there's also speed so if you're shooting on
let's say a reality tv show you pretty much have
to have a zoom lens because you need to be able to
go in and it doesn't mean you're zooming in during
a shot though it could but it also just to reset
is you have a wide shot and then you adjust your
body however you can but you don't want to be
in the way so if you want to get a close-up on a
reality show you just zoom in from where you are
that's kind of like the the very broad strokes but
there's a lot the like a dolly move versus a zoom
in they have a different feel to them and what's
happening to the background is very different and
where your character or your subject in space
the way a zoom as you zoom in it tends to it
flattens the image whereas if you're on a prime
if you're on a 35 millimeter and you're moving in
everything is still staying you're able to
isolate characters more so there are a lot
of qualities that they're so difficult to see
and feel and i'm very lucky because last five
years I've been shooting so much so now I am
at a place where a 20 what a 24 millimeter does
to a let's say a medium close-up shooting that if
you shoot this on a 24 millimeter from right here
and then you move it back just six
inches and you put on a 28 millimeter
I for me there's a big difference between the two
but it's taken just hours so many hours on set and
and looking through different lenses and watching
their effect is what it does to the image some of
it you can explain like if i'm moving my hands
and i'm on a 25 millimeter it's going to be
exaggerated my face will be a little rounder
what does that mean it makes me feel maybe a
little more silly or a little more cartoonish
but if you move back and even though this
the the top and bottom of the frame are exactly
the same on a 50 millimeter none of those things
are exaggerated anymore it's almost a little like
a 50 would be normal and so that becomes a tool
and so then within that you're deciding like a
prime versus a zoom what is worth what are your
trade-offs because on a zoom you can reset really
quickly but primes tend to have more character
to them or be cleaner or so that it's all pros
and cons and and it's it's just like if you're
if you're grabbing grabbing paints if you're
painting your house and they have those swatches
there's like yellow but really it's like this is
goldilocks this one's dandelion this and they have
such subtle differences but there are differences
and that's what lenses kind of bring they all have
different characteristics and zoom and prime are
the two big categories but then even within that
there are a number of different things that will
differentiate one from another and and time money
resources are part of that decision it's not
all purely aesthetic a lot of it is like well
we won't have time to change primes or whatever
like we need to be able to hustle hustle hustle
yeah so it's yeah there's there's a lot there's a
lot in there what's a what's a good starting lens
aside from like sort of the stock camera
lens that's going to come with the body
what would you recommend if somebody wants
to upgrade just a little bit yeah well
so I think choosing a lens if you're starting
if you could only start with one lens
one size and this is assuming because
different cameras have different
size sensors so a 35 millimeter lens
does the lens is always the lens but if your
sensor like our phones have a very small
sensor so a 35 millimeter on the well
that's maybe a bad way to start that
a 35 millimeter is always the lens is the
lens but if you have a large sensor then a
35 millimeter plays very wide and if you have
a smaller sensor then a 35 millimeter plays a
little tighter so your camera but the sort of
standard size is super 35 is the first sensor
so that's what most things are and I would
say assuming you have one of the more common
cameras that I would choose between a 35
or a 50 as the I would lean 35 but I know
most people would lean 50. and I think that's
because they're close-ish to our vision or at
least that's how people say because really in
reality if you pay attention i'm looking at you
but i'm I can see my peripheral vision is pretty
wide so you could argue oh that's a 25 millimeter
but my attention is really on you and you could
argue that that means that i'm not really watching
the outskirts and so really that's a 50 millimeter
and so it's it depends now for me a 35 millimeter
is a really nice size because you can shoot a wide
and you can shoot a close-up but if you get in
close on a 35 it does have a little roundness to
it so it's yeah maybe maybe the answer is a 42
which is a hard lens size to find but yeah I
think those those are the normal hero sizes
I would say is a 35 and a 50 I think would be
the two sizes that one would start with I think
what's the best way to take care of the lenses
so they're not scratched different elements yeah
working with sand for sure yeah lenses require a
lot you need to treat lenses like a like a baby
like they are they are even though a lot of
them are built very rugged the glass is glass
and so i'm very lucky I have a great camera team
and so I rarely touch a lens my first ac second ac
they bring it on they take everything out
they're they're they take everything out with
care they've they're also professionals
they've been doing it for years so
but you do need to treat a lens you need to be
constantly looking at when you take it off and you
put it on you need to check both sides up against
the light because dust particles get in there and
if a dust particle is in the wrong part of frame
it will affect your image sometimes dramatically
so you really need to take care of them some
people will have a a uv filter which is basically
just clear glass it does it functionally
it does serve a bit of a purpose but really
I did that for a long time I've gotten a little
away from it now but I have a set of Rokinons
which are cheap lenses but I think the best bang
for the buck they don't have a ton of personality
but they are really good for their price like
a Rokinon lens and you can get ones that have
gears on them so if you're using a follow focus
and those are like I think for a and they're
really fast really fast I think they're like 200
bucks for a lens and for a good lens with gears on
it that's really fast I think that's the the best
lens you can get in terms of somebody beginning
and I would just choose one of those if you
can and yeah I think that's where I'd start I
still have mine and they used to have those
filters on top in terms of protecting them
but now that i'm more comfortable and i'm like
i'm probably not going to screw this thing up
I don't have live on there but if you're shooting
out in the woods or shooting at the beach or in
the desert is a nightmare for lenses and for
camera sensors it just gets in gears it gets
in the fan and you you everything needs to be
protected and sometimes that's putting plastic or
fabric around it and yeah film equipment strong as
it is you still need to treat it very gently how
long did it take you to fully grasp all the camera
settings I there are a lot of cameras that I
couldn't run but actually most cameras I couldn't
run by myself at this point I don't I am I am
i'm very reliant on my camera team
for sure I am always familiar with how
different camera sensors react to light and
color skin tones the noise floors like I
pay attention to the sensor and the
reactivity but often I am not familiar with
building out a full camera with its wireless
follow I could I couldn't put together a
wireless follow focus and my camera team i'm so
rely i'm reliant on them for a number of things
but for sure they like my first ac bryant I've
been working with him for years i'm reliant on him
for putting together our camera
even when we're ordering equipment
I do broad strokes i'm like I want these lenses
these filters I prefer this monitor but in terms
of the cables and all the little the follow focus
are wireless like I have some leanings but really
I leave that to him and it becomes it's a big
your camera team ends up becoming a huge part
of your whole process and i'm for sure that
way and letting go of some of the technical
elements was tricky for me because I felt like
well wait a minute i'm the cinematographer i'm
supposed to know everything and I was like oh no
no no I need to know how the image will end up
how we get there and the gear that's on the
camera if some of it matters to me because
I have if I know it's handheld i'm going to have
different needs as opposed to if I know i'm going
to be on dolly and all that but yeah in terms
of the the settings or switching things over to
now the alexa mini I've been shooting with that
camera predominantly for the last few years
i'm very familiar with that just because of
the number of times but if I were shooting
on let's say a sony venice or or a red
it's been a while since I've shot on a red
I would probably need help changing the color
temperature or the iso or frame rate or all that
and I have no problem asking for help with that
stuff I don't I don't feel like that's part of my
job description I need to understand it I need to
understand where what i'm looking to get out of it
but getting there i'm content to let my acs help
guide me what technical part of the craft took
you the longest to learn yeah the technical the
cinematography really is technical and actually I
there's a feature that I may be shooting who
knows now but that we might shoot on film and I
am excited but also very nervous about it because
I have I was trained up on film but to light
boldly or dramatically for film is much scarier
than for digital because with all our cameras now
we have a monitor and you can see what
the image is going to look like right now
on film you can't do that you have your
light meter out and you're talking about
like contrast ratios and how
much light is here versus here
and where you can i'm now used to I light
off of my monitor I almost never I bring a
light meter to set I almost never touch it i'm
really using the monitor and to go back to film
scares me a little bit because I want to make sure
I can still be bold with my choices but I have
to make sure that it's not too contrasty or too
too flat like I don't it it's really so I think
it's funny in a way the thing that now intimidates
me or makes me nervous on the technical side
is the thing that I learned first and we've just
because of technology have gotten away from that
and now to go back to it and like oh I don't have
the safety of knowing what my image is going to
look like right away you're kind of you have to
go back to your own faith and understanding the
latitude of a film stock and contrast ratios
how it reacts to color so I think that's the
thing that right now probably makes me the most
nervous on a on a technical level but there are
I think there's also there's there's all kinds
of things like how to bit rates and uh like a
lot of our dslrs for their color it's like 4-2-2
and i'm used to shooting 4-4-4 on an alexa mini
and for a long time I had no concept of what
that is and now I understand oh this is like
the the way it captures color and why that's
important to me is because it allows for gradation
between like different like blues in a sky like it
starts usually by the horizon it's a little gray
gets a little bluer and then deeper blue as you
go up and different camera sensors can't handle
that because of the way they capture color so I
didn't it that isn't something that I ever learned
because I was interested in the technical but
I was interested in like well why why am I not
getting the smoothness of a color transition so
that stuff has come to me kind of just by shooting
it's not like I sat and was studying books
and got it that way it's just kind of learning
because of really broken images and how do I not
break this image next time that kind of thing
were you one of these kids that used to take
things apart to see how they worked I was always
curious so I would take things apart but not to
see how they worked I would take things apart
because I was just like I wonder what the inside
of this looks like sounds like a serial killer
but yeah no I actually I would not call myself
a technical cinematographer now I that might
not be true I may actually be and I realize
sometimes like oh I know more stuff than I thought
but I never the leader of it is always like how
does this image feel like I look at when new
cameras get announced I will look at the specs but
what I've learned is that like listing the specs
on paper kind of don't matter to me now they give
me a baseline they help me understand frame rates
how will it do in low light what is its native iso
like there are technical things that I now am very
familiar with and I understand what that means but
really I need to look at footage because the way
that they capture motion the way that they capture
skin tones the way that they like the highlights
the way they blow out like those are so my my
technical the technical information of cameras
has always been secondary to my aesthetic reaction
to it my emotional reaction to the image for sure
yeah I think you probably do know a lot more
than you think but that maybe goes along with
the humility so well I also think it's just years
of doing it like some of it just has has come
because I've I haven't understood why something
is a certain way and so it's out of necessity but
yeah I would say out of necessity like i'm
just like what is it what is this and so I've
but I've really I've been in it for so long
so it's yeah I think that knowledge has just
come almost through osmosis just through wading
through it for so long do you prefer more setups
and shots or less setups and shots for a project
yeah I would the fewer setups generally the
happier I am that's not to say that's always the
right way but I do notice there's there's if i'm
if we're hosing down a scene meaning okay we
need to wide and then maybe we get a second
wide from here then we need this medium and
then let's go in for the close-up but then also
I don't enjoy that I feel like you're just chasing
and you're basically gathering pieces so that they
can make it in an edit so that in the edit so
really and this happens with a lot of projects
they're basically creating it in the editing room
and nothing wrong with that but for me personally
that doesn't interest me that much I want to feel
like we're making conscious decisions on set and
also the fewer the this is what I tell directors
a lot too is the fewer the number of shots
the higher the quality so the
more shots you're shooting
the lower the quality each shot will be just out
of necessity like you you can't make it and so
for me trying to be intentional about why you're
shooting don't just shoot a close-up because you
need a close-up in every scene like maybe we
saved this then it's more powerful when you use
a close-up in the next scene is being intentional
about how it goes is very important to me
because otherwise I don't feel like i'm doing
anything I feel like anybody could do it and
that's fine i'm not super interested in that
so yeah so for me the fewer the setups oh man
I'd love to shoot just like a couple shots a day I
might get bored if that were actually the case but
that implies to me that we're really structuring
something and you're moving the camera moves
when it needs to move and it will become and
over the shoulder like that that these things
progress and grow and a shot can be multiple
things in one set up that's that's something I
really love it's hard but I think it really plays
beautifully in the end if you approach it that way
you use intentional is that was
that from the four agreements
do that oh that is I read that I read that when
I was going through a bad breakup some years ago
yeah yeah yeah is that be intentional with your
word I think or something is that one of them
why is it don louise miguel or forget forgive
me for the author's name but I thought that that
was part of the the book but I could be wrong
that it was about the power of intention and
the intention of our thoughts yeah it might
be yeah yeah yeah I find I find that that's
it's a big part of I think how I approach
my work is just what is this about and
let that drive because you can
shoot any scene anyway and so
but that's not the point like the the point is
this is a film about loneliness or this is a film
about family and so okay well what does that mean
family is warmth okay so that means maybe when the
family's together that means maybe that the dinner
table is warmer literally the color temperature is
warmer and it feels cozy but then when they're out
in the world it's cooler and lonely or handheld or
it can very quickly lead your decisions and
that's how I like to work I think that there's
there should be reason behind your decisions
do you put a metaphysical element to a lot of
I try yeah I try yeah for sure I've got a
lot of hippie in me and so I love because
it's still ultimately you're looking for
emotional reactions to things you want to create
emotional reactions from the audience and so I
think like letting letting the whole thing be
ethereal if it needs to be like I often
the way when i'm starting a new project
often I don't know what it wants to look like or
feel like and I'll just start going through images
images and films and music and just gather and
with the director or an actor whoever else are
the creatives involved is I just like to gather
and and going back to the soup metaphor it's just
like well okay you don't like carrots all
right so let's not put any carrots in this
soup and it's like okay well do you like
a spicy soup oh okay so let's start adding
and and slowly it really it doesn't feel
like i'm making decisions it really does
often feel like the project is slowly revealing
itself to me when it's working really well it does
feel like there's a magic to it and that the
the project almost already exists somewhere
or like it's a little creature somewhere and
it's just slowly you're like oh I think this
creature is furry I think it's got a blue tint
to it and it just like it starts to make sense
visually which is it's a weird way to think about
it but I find so pleasurable because it feels
like i'm hunting for something and then slowly
you start to see glimpses of it and I love that
do you like things to be a challenge in
a sense yeah I well it's interesting I
if i'm not if i'm not maybe instead
of challenged it's if i'm not engaged
in some way like i'm i'm feeling like i'm adding
something to it and i'm working towards something
I can get bored for sure I i'm not i'm not
attracted to things that are just like oh it's
fine it's whatever you just kind of put a light on
this side and we'll shoot it and we'll figure it
out like I get bored I definitely get bored so I
maybe I do need to get challenged I at least need
to be engaged I need to find something to hook
me in there have been there have been projects
that have come my way that I was like this is
just not a good fit i'm not this isn't something
i'm interested enough in I want to make sure i'm
interested because it's just so much time this is
your life you're gonna spend half a year working
on this thing so half a year of your life like
it'd be nice if you care in some way one way or
another yeah what's it like to shoot an average
seven to ten pages a day yeah so shooting shooting
seven to ten pages a day is is how a lot of tv
goes that's one of the things I'll look at often
is sometimes when i'm being interviewed for a
job or close to being hired sometimes by then
they have a page count and a number of shooting
days and one of the first questions I will ask is
like how many how many pages a day are we shooting
because it will tell me some element about how
hard this job is going to be I shot a show that
we were averaging I think we were averaging over
10 pages a day and it sucks it's you're just like
okay like just put up one light somewhere and
you're just going and number of characters
that's actually secretly that almost dictates
more than because I've noticed yeah number of
shooting days versus number of pages versus number
of characters because if there is one person
that you're shooting there are only so many
shots of one person you need to do but if
there are eight people in a room and it's even
just a two-page scene but everybody needs their
own coverage I shot I shot a show I shot two
seasons of a show that has I don't know maybe
12 or 13 main characters and sometimes they all
get together for dinner and it is a nightmare
of 180 lines and where and it is it's
really i'm glad in hindsight i'm glad
I've done it because now I feel like I have a
good handle and approach on those but those are
really difficult scenes and so two pages with 12
actors is harder than 10 pages with two actors
so that so it's an interesting added dynamic
it's like exponentially more difficult for every
additional character that's in a room unless you
have a director who's very intentional like sure
sure there are sure there are 11 people in here
but only this person matters and when they have
the the fortitude to just stick with that and
actually all we really need is a shot that
pushes in here and maybe a wide or that's great
but usually everybody wants to cover their butt
and so they're like well we're going to
need a close-up here and close up and they
generally people which bums me out but they
every line of dialogue that's spoken by anybody
they're like well we have to get that in this
shot it's like you don't have to actually and
most of the great filmmakers don't bother with
that it's again it's intention it's what's the
scene about it's not about every person hopefully
though sometimes it is it's usually focused in
on one or two people their dynamic and you're
trying to capture that and so you let that lead
your decisions but yeah if it's if it's a high
number of pages that you're shooting per day
it's challenging it's really hard and I do
not enjoy it the lower the number of pages
it's similar to setups if if it's fewer pages
they're going to be shot better they're going
to be it's going to be more cinematic or more
intentional and if it's a high page count
i hope I get another job offer then
because it's tough it's exhausting
and you and it really the really what gets
sacrificed first is the light your light you
just can't you can't shape the light as
much because you need to look generally
so many different directions and so it's a lot
trickier to be intentional about your lighting
how many times do you read a screenplay before
you step on set that's a really good question
whenever yeah it's funny whenever I start a
new project and and it's I get this the script
I always think i'm gonna read it a million
times I think i'm gonna read it every night
and inevitably other things come my way and I
end up not reading it as many times as I want
but that said I read scenes so I won't read it
beginning to end that many times a few times
certainly right at the beginning but then it's re
really becomes it very quickly turns into a puzzle
so it's almost like you're given the puzzle all as
a finished piece and then almost immediately you
break it up and then it's little puzzle pieces and
you're like okay this one we're gonna do on day 17
this one and you almost separate it out and
so it and so I'll read the scenes a number of
times but as a whole I might not revisit it
again it's very it's strange but also in tv
there are rewrites happening all the time so
you have to reread because there are new drafts
coming and sometimes this has not
happened much but it has happened
where there's a rewrite that happens and
you're in week nine and there's a rewrite and
I will have missed an email or something and
I won't realize and will be on set and like oh
this is where they walk out to the kitchen you're
like no no no they go to sleep I remember this and
like no no in the rewrite now it goes and you're
like oh no like I didn't and so you scramble
and it sucks when that happens but it does happen
tv and different shows some shows are rewriting
as you're on set Pen 15 has a lot of improv which
is a little different but they will improvise and
as we're doing it they'll we'll realize oh this
affects a scene that we have to shoot next week
or this affects a scene we've already shot so the
whole thing does need to be in my head pretty well
so it's I guess the answer is I never read it
enough I always think i'm going to read it more
but it's always close i'm
always if I have a minute
especially on the day the morning of I reread the
scenes that we're shooting for the day for sure to
refresh but then I also try to look at for every
scene that you're shooting you look to either side
of it like where did we just come out of and then
what are we going back into because that affects
your first and last shot in a sequence too because
you want it to you don't want it to be jarring
when it cuts to the next thing so you're trying to
hold a lot in your mind do you take any notes or
storyboard when you're going through a script yeah
I don't storyboard when i'm reading a script but I
do take notes I take a lot of notes on but it's
especially at the beginning it's very loose it
it's whatever occurs to me like sometimes that's
an actual shot I'll write down oh slow zoom in
or big wide or what whatever whatever that is or
get a close-up of the scissors anything whatever
that for what if it strikes me but often and
sometimes it's something a little broader like
oh handheld maybe this is a handheld moment or
maybe this is static or maybe some it's rare
at the beginning but sometimes like a color might
occur to me something really I'll let myself jot
down anything and then I'll let future me decide
if that's relevant or not but I do take notes
I don't storyboard and I have rarely worked with
directors who storyboard unless it's a commercial
because it's so much smaller it's much easier or
if there's a difficult sequence difficult can be
maybe it's an action sequence or it's
just like let's say four people in a car
can get very confusing and so sometimes
I'll have directors who will storyboard
because they want to make sure like oh this
and like that everything's kind of intentional
but usually it's shot lists and so it'll be a list
of like wide medium close-up on her we need to
zoom for this moment and it's a list and that's
kind of your guide and your map and very often
that all changes on the day maybe because
an actor goes a certain way or maybe because
you have a new idea but having that plan goes a
long way and even if you never use a single shot
it means because there are going to be days
where you're not feeling it where you're
not like you're just whatever the actors are out
of it or the directors out of it or i'm out of it
and then you have something to fall back on that
will still work like this is still going to this
is this is still a recipe that in the end you
have a scene so I think it's really important to
have that really important to plan and talk that
out but then on the day always being ready for
something better and or if just something changes
dramatically you lose a location or whatever
I think being able to to improvise is
really valuable do you come up with your own
shot list or do you always leave that up to the
director generally the director brings a shot list
very often we do that together that's
the ideal is that a director and I
the really the best what I find
is is the best way it's just
generally not practical is to be able to go with
the director to a location and be up on your feet
and actually like walk around use the phone
as a little like take pictures we'll do that
that is that's the ideal rarely do you have time
to go ahead of time with a director to a location
usually you have to pay for locations whenever
you're there so but yeah generally it's with a
director you sit through each scene and you talk
it out and you're kind of imagining how actors
might move in the space and what moments do you
need but sometimes the director will just come
with their own shot list that they've done
on their own and then I look through it we
talk through it maybe I have suggestions really
where I think one of the strengths that I have is
on the day because you're always battling
time is watching the directors and actors
walk through a scene when I can see it up on
its feet I can often figure out a way to combine
two or three shots into one like oh if she starts
here and then she walks to there and I slide the
camera here then we'll actually get both of those
shots on your list like that's that's something
that I think is very helpful for time but also
trying to cut down on the number of shots just
for for to try and control the edit a little bit
to tell the story again with intention is that
it's like well instead of just get putting the
camera here and then putting it here and putting
it here and putting it here it's like maybe we
can travel maybe this actor's move can pull the
camera and now you're in a new setup that gets
you this other thing that you you wanted so but
it's a it's a combination for sure and different
directors some are better at shot listings some
are worse some hate it some love it and so I have
to be kind of amenable to all of that how much do
you plan out the day before your shoot the ideal
is that every day is very well planned out and
that doesn't mean it won't change because it will
change but the ideal is that way now that said
sometimes working on series you don't get time to
prep with the directors some directors come in and
let's say they're doing episodes four and five and
they you've hopefully met them but even sometimes
you're meeting them on the day and they're
coming in and they've done their own prep
that's separate from you and you try to do your
best to work with them and I know on bigger shows
that happens a lot like the csi's of the world
directors come in and out and they don't get
a lot of time with their cinematographers and
that's that's got to be scary that has to be very
challenging I've been lucky enough that that's
rare for me usually I get some time with them but
very often they will a director will come
in with a plan that I have never seen before
and then I will depending on their
comfort level I will try and make that fit
like our location a little more or the feel of
the show because I've been shooting it for a while
so i'm like oh normally we won't zoom here or
whatever that is so it's yeah it varies and it's
and then there are I have worked with directors
where there we just have a good rhythm and we
just kind of wing it like we we show
up on the day and i'm pretty good at
if I have actors and a director and
all that I can figure out what shots
create a scene for sure so but that's
taken years of shooting shows for sure
but at this point I feel pretty comfortable with
that how do an actor is the real deal I suppose
like anything there are many different ways
for actors to be quote unquote good or bad
and I think you can I've started to think
about them a little bit like athletes and
some work harder than others
some have some natural talent
but there are also specialty kind of approaches
like let's say like a a quirky actor like a
specialty three-point shooter it doesn't mean
that this person is good at all the things
but cast correctly casting I guess is really
part of it if they're in the right spot you
put them in a position to succeed so one person
can really shine if they're in the right role and
it's a well-written role of course whereas that
same person you could see on a different set on
a different day in a different role and you're
like oh I don't know about that like it's so
there are a number of factors that said every once
in a while and I would not know how to to quantify
it but every once in a while I find myself behind
the camera and i'm watching something i'm like oh
this person's gonna be around forever like you
there's just something I guess back in the day
you would think of that like oh they've got it
I hesitate to put it that way but that said I
have seen that I've seen actors were like oh
like that's me I had I had the good fortune of
working with matt damon on on a tiny little like
a youtube thing I watched george clooney work and
they are so prepared and so comfortable there's
like a confidence that they carry with them
they treated everybody around them phenomenally
well they were very loose but then when it came to
time to work they could snap right in
you could tell they had done the work
so all all of this stuff whereas other
actors come they don't know their lines
and so I think part of it is just preparation
truly and on set that comes across as like
wow they're really talented but really it's
just that they put in the work so I think
that's part of it but I often find myself
surprised when i'm on set and it's time to
do a scene and this person's been around and
then all of a sudden the camera's rolling and
this like they morph into something else so I
don't know where some of these things come from
I know some of it is work it's prep but some
of it that maybe there is just a natural thing
I don't know I don't know it's a little bit
of magic I think I don't know I continue to
wonder the same thing yeah what other
qualities are you looking for in an actor
it's interesting so for me because I
have no power over choosing an actor
in my position as a cinematographer the actors
are chosen so whoever's there like i'm gonna do
whatever I can do with them there are
little treats that some actors bring
there are some actors who just physically their
eyes will catch a light really well they have like
big or big brown eyes let's say and they're just
almost no matter where they are they'll always
catch a little bit of light and then some actors
their eyes are a little like deeper I think I have
kind of smallish eyes and it can get tricky
because like an eye light can go a long way
when you're lighting somebody in terms of creating
an empathy there's something really magical about
an ilite and some actors it's hard to get the
eyelight you're like trying to find the spot
and some of them won't take it so that's a that's
a purely physical thing that they have no control
over so there are like treats like that sometimes
i'm like oh this and skin tones different actors
they have you're just like oh this like takes the
the the warmth really well so there are little
things like that but a I guess as with most people
on a set there really is to somebody being kind
and professional being prepared that's a actually
preparation is maybe one of the biggest things
because we I've a number of times in my life we
I have with the director we plan this shot where
oh they're going to take them out the door we're
going to dolly all the way down and then they sit
here and then they're going to interact with this
person and get in their car and go and then the
actor can't get through their lines and you have
to reapproach the entire scene and do it because
somebody doesn't know their lines and sometimes
that's hard because they have a ton of lines and
that's brutal I wouldn't be able to do that but
sometimes it's a lack of preparation so I guess
yeah I suppose for all the all the random things
I just named I want a prepared actor somebody is
taking it seriously because like it it affects
my ability to do a good job if somebody comes in
unprepared so I think something as basic as
that is about all you can ask from somebody
is don't be a dick and be prepared that's that
goes a long way so if someone is not prepared then
you're doing numerous retakes people are reading
them their lines it's constant yeah there's
there's constant like you have to reset you have
to take it all in pieces and if they can only get
a few lines at a time it means you have to cut to
something else because in the edit you need when
they're when they're resetting you have to cut
so it's forcing your hand in an edit and you have
to rethink the way you're building a scene which
can mean this is not the way we intended or this
isn't this isn't going to feel the way we want
this to feel but you have to because and and look
I say that as though it's really easy that you're
doing a shoot especially if there's one or two
lead characters and they have to memorize lines
for 15 weeks every day and scripts are being
rewritten it is a big ask that is a big load
that these actors are carrying like it really
I empathize with them it's really hard acting
is I know we all tend to think of it as like oh
celebrity and you're famous here it is brutal it
is hard work especially if you're on a tv show
scripts are changing you have tons of dialogue
and then on top of that you have all these people
whispering in your ear I have to gauge when we do
it let's say we're shooting a scene and an actor
on top of all their lines maybe a director gives
them dire oh no this part don't forget you need
to be sad in this little thing but then come back
up but then for me I maybe need an actor to land
in a certain spot and maybe they haven't and I
will have to gauge going back to reading the room
if they seem overwhelmed I won't give them that
note on the first take I will like let them get
a little more comfortable and then if I can do
anything on my side to adjust maybe we tweak a
light maybe I move my camera then I'll do that
otherwise i'm waiting until they're comfortable
and then as gently as I can just like hey don't
forget like after you get up from the dinner table
I need you to land in this area and
I have to be very careful because
I am lower priority you want the performance
to to work if the performance doesn't work
it doesn't matter how pretty my light is
you want the performance to lead so for me
I have to make sure an actor is comfortable
and that they feel comfortable with me and then
gauging when they're too overwhelmed or it's okay
now to give them a no or sometimes some directors
prefer me to give notes sometimes I go to the
director and I say hey you need to remind them
that they have to get to this area and things
like that so there are lots of little things that
actors are constantly being bombarded with
it's so I think for for a cinematographer or
a camera operator it's really important to
have empathy and realize that these actors
even if you don't like them they are carrying a
lot and you need to protect them and their space
their headspace and the physical space that
you're working in yeah that's why I always
and I've said this numerous times when people
say oh well so-and-so doesn't want to hang out
in between takes and they just go back into
their dressing room but I think that they
would need that time oh man I would not I would
definitely not hang out in between takes like
there's no way there's just so much and people
especially if an actor has any kind of celebrity
people get a little googly eyed and a little
and they want to interact they want to be able
to go home to their spouse and just be like I was
talking with george clooney about chicken today
but they are there's so much going on for them
so I do my best to like just stay out of their
way because there's there's really a lot of people
are really pulling at actors attentions same with
directors too but they don't have usually that
celebrity attached and people get people get
weird around celebrity unfortunately how do if
a director is the real deal he had directors are
directors are kind of the the biggest
wild card on a set in terms of well
it's close between actors and directors but a
director dictates so much of how a job goes for me
it's a bit and it's a big part of why I will say
yes or no to a job for sure is the director uh
boy
well I think going back to something we talked
about earlier is I need to feel engaged and
creatively engaged and if i'm not
it might not be the right job for me
and the directors usually who dictates that and
because and sometimes that's because they want
a ton of control sometimes it's because
they don't know what they want at all
or maybe their aesthetic is very different from
mine so I don't know that I'd think of it as like
a good or a bad director it's more about like a
match it's it's almost like a romantic partnership
it doesn't mean if you if you are dating somebody
it doesn't mean it's that they are good or bad
it's just how well do you mesh with them how
how are your how does your communication work
what is your taste what are you trying to
get to when you're working on something so I
it really does feel like a romantic partnership
in a way because it's pretty intimate and you
are relying on each other and you're going to be
around each other in very stressful situations
when you're tired you're hungry things aren't
working out how do you react how do they react
and can you and I've been very fortunate I I've I
get along with most of the directors I work with
but I absolutely have had directors that I
can tell like aren't very fond of because
there's my own joy and happiness and sometimes
the project itself that can only bring so much
joy or happiness but the the there are directors
that like i'm like oh this just isn't isn't going
great like it's just not working out and I and I
do think my job is to serve them for the most part
and so I try to do my best but it doesn't always
work but it yeah it's I don't know there's a weird
chemistry you try to gauge
up front as best you can
will this be a good match but until you're in the
trenches with somebody you don't know how it'll be
what's the mark of a professional
a professional director that maybe
a newer director someone a little more green
won't have as many traits or practices habits
yeah directing such an interesting one there's a
there's a joke that you'll hear sometimes on set
like who has the least amount of experience
on a set and almost always it's the director
it's just the nature of getting to a directing
position can be very that sometimes it's who
sometimes you wrote a script
and you're being who knows and
i think one of the things that's that has to be
the most challenging for a new director or an
inexperienced director is there's this big machine
moving and at this point for somebody like me like
I have a lot more to learn but I've been doing
it for a long time and so when we're looking
at a scene and an actor's like oh I actually I
don't want to sit here I want to get up and I
want to go by the stand by the window is for some
directors that might freak them out completely
they because they they don't know they've made
a plan and then as soon as something breaks in
the plan be that an actor's decision or
maybe bad weather or a location falls
through or there's an equipment malfunction
is the ability to change and still whatever
that intention of the scene is is that you can
still find it but using none of what you planned
and I think for a newer director that's
got to be so hard is finding for me
one of the things i'm good at is I think i'm
good at at least is sequencing like in a scene
it's like okay well we don't need this close-up
because we're going to come around and when that
when she walks through here this shot will land
so we'll have that line dialogue here and then
we need to be cam shooting or like I can very
quickly piece together like okay this is all the
okay yeah we'll have all the pieces and a lot
of directors can't do that they they just just
simply by because of not being not having shot as
much so it doesn't mean necessarily good or bad
but that ability to think on your feet I think
is one of the most valuable things especially
for tv because it's so fast paced or lower budget
feature you you just can't stop you have to go go
and I think that's probably probably one
of the biggest things and and I don't know
i don't know how to like advise a director
exactly because some of it is just hours
just putting in just doing it doing it more and
learning so so I guess going back to similar to
my job or an actor's job is preparation is
knowing that they know what a scene or a whole
piece needs to feel like or be like and then the
ability to improvise I guess if you're too rigid
and then something falls apart will
you be able to adjust I guess that's
and maybe not and maybe there
are directors like david fincher
who are just like he is going to get what he
wants the way he wants it so it's not like being
precise is wrong it's just on the shows
I've been on you can't like you can't
get everything perfectly and so how do you
still make it work yeah generally speaking
what's an appropriate amount of time a director
should give a cinematographer to light a scene
uh in terms of time to light a scene there's
definitely no answer because so like no no strict
answer because it all depends on the size of a
shoot and maybe the better way to think about it
is how much time do you need do they do the actors
need because you the more time I take to light the
less time actors have to act the fewer takes a
director gets to direct so that's all part of
the factor and then also how many scenes you have
that day if you're in one location for the day and
it's one time of day one mood then I can take a
lot more time at the beginning of the day because
we're never moving but if we have to do three
location moves that day we need to we need to
start shooting as soon as possible so it's kind of
a big math problem because I could light a scene
for two years like there's no such thing as like
okay i'm done now it's perfect I could go forever
and so the things that caused me to
be like all right it's good enough or
whatever is what else is in play and and there's
an ad somewhere nearby that is like hey are you
done like there's somebody generally around but it
really depends on the scale because if you you can
light a scene with no lights if you do the
right time of day in the right location
that that's it you just if you plan
it out you're like if we are here
at 7 30 and the camera's ready to go we need to
shoot at 7 30 because by 8 30 the light's no good
anymore and then we have to come in and supplement
it and that'll take a whole hour or whatever so
so every scene is a little different you
definitely fall into rhythms last show I shot
the beginning of the day is always slower because
people are unloading equipment and all that
but we would block through a scene and
then I talked to the director and the a.d
and I I'll we'll kind of run through okay we
need seven shots for this scene and I'll be
like okay well this side I need 40 minutes let's
say to light this but then we have a turn around
and I need to reset the light for that and so
that means that's going to be another maybe
20 minutes and so it's every scene every day
every location every shot is kind of its own
animal honestly so it's you have to be constantly
thinking about that but it's yeah it just varies
anywhere from zero minutes to a day of lighting
truthfully like it could it can really be anywhere
in between have you been on set where it's
been six hours worth of lighting one shot
well so there are scenes if there is a scene
where for instance like a long one or like a
steady cam that goes through a restaurant we did
that on my last show there's a steadicam shot that
starts in a parking lot it comes into a restaurant
goes in through the kitchen back out through the
rest of the restaurant into another room where
then there's a whole family waiting for them so
I don't so what we did is we basically lit the
whole restaurant and the outdoor parking lot
and that took I don't remember but it's probably
half a day but then it meant that we were mostly
lit so not only did we do that steadicam shot but
then you jump into doing your dialogue scenes and
the light you kind of you sort of light 360. and
so in theory you can point any direction and you
can shoot now ideally you are able to tweak this
and that but yeah for if you if you can capture
a lot of material or light a whole space that's
something I try to do when I can is lighting
a space a little more because then it allows
you like okay we've gotten these shots but now
we bump in here we don't need to tweak the light
oh we turn here we don't need to tweak the light
now that's hard and it's hard to make look good
but that is that is one way of approaching it so
a lot more time up front but then you just crank
how do you decide when to move the camera and when
not to move the camera yeah moving the camera
is it's interesting because and and often the
director and I will discuss in pre-production
because some some directors or projects
want constant movement that maybe it's like
a light float but that it's just always
moving in some capacity and then on other
projects or other directors it's like no
only moves when it's a very specific and important
beat I've had shows where we didn't move the
camera period and I've had shows where it's
never still and so it really just it so depends
on the project and the director really because
some of it's just taste and I will have my own
takes on it like if I feel like well moving in
this scene this is such a this this character
is really sad and if the camera's moving around
it's going to feel too sexy or too exciting and
maybe because it's always moving maybe
now it being static is going to accentuate
that because we're used to it moving and vice
versa so context really dictates all of it but
you do want there to be a reason not even
if it's a show where everything's moving
why is it always moving you don't like it's tricky
when when the reason is oh it's just cool like
it's not that that's wrong there's
no right or wrong but for me again
thoughtfulness is so important to me like why
are things happening and if the
reason is because it's cool like
that's not wrong it's just less exciting
it's harder for me to sink my teeth into that
and I think I can get lazy I get if it's
just like well there's no i'm just kind of
sliding the camera around then I if i'm not
thinking about what i'm doing by by day three
just like what what am I doing here so so it's
tricky but you want you want traveling with like
something that david fincher going back to finches
something he does because he's he's a his style of
filmmaking freaks me out a little bit because it's
so controlled and I get nervous like would I even
be able to survive a david fincher shoot I don't
know but his camera tends to lock into actors if
actors are moving the camera's moving and they're
in sync and that's pretty impressive like when
somebody's getting up and sitting down the camera
but that takes he does 100 takes of stuff like it
that's hard that's really hard work but that's
an approach that makes sense is if actor moves
camera moves factors still cameras still but
there is just there is everywhere a michael bay
thing camera's always alive but that's because
he wants it all to be a roller coaster ride
and so it's not again it's not wrong it's
just like that's the that's the aesthetic
so I guess it starts from a vision and then
hopefully the camera's movement or lack thereof
at least there's like a string connecting it to
that original vision and again intention did you
see uncut gems it did yes that's it yeah uncut
gems constantly moving camera which makes that
that character is constantly moving so yeah
that's a perfect example of something that
like there's a reason for that and then it's
just like go go go because it's a whirlwind
his whole life is a whirlwind yeah especially in
the jewelry store or out on the street yeah it
was just constant and and and I think it works so
well for that film and it was it really conveyed
who he was as a character what his world was like
yeah that's actually a much better example because
I know michael bay brings a lot of like people
have a lot of associations but uncut gems is a
great example of constant camera movement for a
reason and very effective it feels very chaotic
yeah that's great what tools or equipment should
a beginning cinematographer buy early because
they're going to be using them all the time that's
a good question I think if you can get a fast lens
I think that is a very useful tool a
lens that can opens up to at least a two
let's say well I'd say two eight is a good
minimum but if you can get something like these
rokinons I mentioned those are a 1.5 or something
I think a fastlands is a very valuable tool
for a couple reasons one you can shoot in lower
light situations so just just helps when you don't
have a lot of gear but also it can teach you about
depth of field because you can get to the extreme
and you can see what a very shallow depth of
field can do for you which but also a deep
depth of field so I think that's one of the I
would probably start there and then beyond that
I think it's getting easier now but like a strong
light but those are hard to find cheap but a
strong light source I've noticed if you can
have a strong light source coming in a window
it gives you such a great baseline to start
from but usually a bigger light is something
that requires a bigger crew and more money so
that's maybe a little more wishful thinking
there's an app called sun seeker and I think there
are a couple other versions but it can tell you
where the sun will be at any time of day on any
day of the year and if you can really choose those
spots I use it for 100 of the spot unless i'm in
a set where there are no windows I want to know
where the sun is going to be and when and then i'm
going to use that to decide what direction we face
and what time of day we want to shoot there so I
think that that's an indispensable tool as far as
i'm concerned it's kind of expensive but I think
it's worth its weight in gold and actually along
those lines there's an app called Artemis which
you can put in any camera and any set of lenses
and it will ingest that and then you can take
it you can be like oh I want to see on an Alexa
mini 50 millimeter from this position that's what
this will look like oh actually no we're shooting
a different camera it's going to be a black
magic it's going to be the 6k pocket cam and we
only have a 40 millimeter you plug it in and same
thing so you can really get a sense of what each
lens is going to show you in a space so I think
those are those are I use both of those tools
constantly on every set I've been on for sure
so I think those are huge yeah I think those are
those would be the big ones anything maybe hold
off on it's not as necessary I I think we have
we all have obsessions with cameras like
camera brands and I think nowadays especially
what you can get with a 1 000 camera blows
my mind and I think there are benefits to
cameras like an alexa or red or whatever they
all have they all have their advantages but
not feeling like you have to get a
high-end camera to shoot a high-end image
that is not the case anymore I would say
one thing if your camera does not have
internal nd filters neutral density filters one
piece of gear that I think you do need are neutral
density filters and they have nowadays a bunch
of different brands of variable nds and that's
something that you can screw on to the end of a
lens and you can twist it and it will allow more
or less light into your camera and there are
a number of reasons that that's beneficial but
it allows you to start being conscious about
shooting at certain f-stops it gives you control
so like shooting I've shot shows where we're
really opening up and it's a shallower depth
of field a little aimed more toward beauty and
you're shooting at like a a two or for a lot of
it but then there are other times where i'm like
no we're gonna shoot at a four and it's deeper
depth of field and it feels different but you
you don't have that control unless you have a
neutral density filter so that's something to get
but in terms of yes I think not obsessing about
quality of your camera I think that's something
that we all get hung up on but the the what you
can get now is it just boggles my mind it's
unbelievable so I think the this the floor has
come up so high in terms of the floor of your
image is always going to be pretty good now
in terms of what the camera can give you
at least so yeah not obsessing about an
expensive camera is probably a big thing can you
dispel the myth can you really fix it in post
I hate fixing it in post I am not a believer in
fixing it in post for one it will often not get
fixed in post because just like in production
when you run out of time and money people run
out of time and money and post and so a lot of
things end up just getting tossed by the wayside
and it's important to know when
you can fix something if you're
you're on set and you're running out of time and
you're you're the sun is going down it's like well
we're almost out of light but we can still shoot
this but in post they're gonna have to pull it
up it's not gonna look as good but the range it's
like we can get it to a certain so sometimes out
of necessity but I hate fixing it in post I think
it's when you start hearing that which you will
hear all the time and I will say it sometimes
but that should never be where you land if you
don't have to and then when you have to that's the
beauty you can do so much in post these days but
you shouldn't set out with that as your initial
attitude for sure you've been asked to do a
commencement speech at a college what are
your final words to young cinematographers
upcoming generation of filmmakers cinematographers
you yeah I never would have guessed this and
I touched on this earlier but coming into this
industry I never would have guessed how far
kindness can get you being pleasant to work with
people are I've gotten I don't know what other
cinematographers do but a lot of them apparently
it's not good because the amount of times
that different departments specifically art
department but and sound and costume that
will come up to me and i'm not i'm not
mother teresa i'm just a normal person
the amount of times that departments come up to
me like andy you're so nice I love working with
you it feels like they've been abused puppies that
somebody's now giving them a biscuit like i'm not
so for me and I same with producers I've had
producers tell me outright that the reason
that they rehire me is because of the atmosphere
I create on set not the visual atmosphere just the
vibe and I never would have thought that that
would get me work that never even occurred to
me i'm thankful that that's true it's been good
for my career but I think remembering that this
is your life like the way you spend your day
today is your life and when you're on set if you
suck to be around if you're unpleasant to
be around that is not gonna serve you and
what an amazing gift that being nice and happy
can be good for your career like that that feels
too good to be true but that's exactly what
I've found and so I think embracing film has
opened me up as a person got me to be more
confident less shy because I love it so much
and if it's also teaching me to meditate and
be kinder I never yell I never ever yell on
set I want to yell but I don't it's teaching
me to like control my emotions don't blow up
be patient that's I just it it brings me
so much joy to think that being better at
my career makes me a better person and being
a better person makes me better at my career
so I would think that's the best piece of
advice is allow your goodness as a person to
help you be a better craftsman better to work with
everybody wants that I would assume in every field
you said you went on some road trips
after 2009 you kind of you you didn't
really have that much weighing you down and
what did you see on some of these road trips
yeah I i'm the big there was some quote that
somebody once told me that Akira Kurosawa said and
then I've tried to find it and I've never found it
so I have no idea somebody just said it to me but
to be a good filmmaker live an
interesting life and I spent
a good chunk of my late 20s and early 30s living a
weird life on the road I was traveling I slept on
couches I slept in cars I slept on the
ground like I was I was adventuring I was
I was living a life and I was looking at the world
around me like literally just looking at the world
part of that is looking at light but part
of that seeing mountains in the snow versus
desert in in the summer versus the
seeing an ocean a quiet lake a busy city
these all have a feeling to them and emotion and
having that experience you never know what kind
of script will come your way and what you'll
be able to touch on and then ultimately people
is to to connect with strangers a stranger on
a bus in the middle of italy or wherever to
to connect with different people or just watching
people I think that just gives you it gives you a
richer life which then gives you a richer palette
to pull from when you're coming up with ideas so I
really am a big bully now I do wonder sometimes
had I maybe started my career a little earlier
would I be further along now but what I did in my
late 20s early 30s this kind of vagabond life was
interesting and I would imagine it's painted by
experience which I bring to my work for sure so
I think making sure i'm a huge film nerd but
living some life outside of movies I think is a
very valuable thing connect with the
world around you as best you can.
What do you like about Andy’s story?